this is Joo podcast number 407 with Eko
Charles and me Joo willink good evening
Eko good
evening we all face challenges we all
have
setbacks we all
suffer when these difficulties hit some
people break they surrender they let
circumstances fate and events that
unfold control their attitude dictate
their emotional state and determine
their
Destiny they adopt a defeated attitude
of negativity they accept
failure they curl up in a ball and wait
for the clock to run
out they
quit but there are other people who are
diametrically opposed to that attitude
people who in spite of incredible
challenges adapt and
overcome of every person I have ever met
in my life Travis Mills has faced the
most traumatic in intense and brutal
challenges a human being could face and
he faces these severe challenges
continuously every day over and over
again and yet he has the best attitude
of anyone I know or have ever
known his emotional state is always
positive his humor is always on point
his mentality is pure strength of
will despite suffering the most horrific
wounds imaginable he chooses his own
destiny and is Unstoppable in his drive
and commitment to live
life Travis Mills is one of my friends
one of my heroes and the most inspiring
human being I have ever
met Travis received injuries beyond all
comprehension while serving in the US
army in Afghanistan an improvised
explosive device big enough to destroy a
vehicle
ripped off his arms and legs leaving him
a quadruple
amputee in that moment of shock and
despair when most people would be
focused on themselves Travis's first
response was directing the medic tending
to him to care for his fellow soldiers
instead he thought he was going to
die against the odds and thanks to the
skill and determination of those Medics
he
lived but his battle was far from over
in fact it was just
beginning Upon returning to America he
started an almost unbearable journey of
recovery and
recalibration countless surgeries
excruciating pain hallucinations
fighting to stay
alive then he had to learn how to live
again he had to learn to utilize
prosthetic limbs he had to learn how to
walk eat and accomplish seemingly
ordinary tasks like getting dressed and
brushing his
teeth he also had to recreate his
identity now that he could no longer
serve in his beloved
Army and most important he had to
recalculate and reimagine how he could
be the husband and father he knew his
family
deserved this was not an easy path
I cannot think of anything in life more
difficult to
overcome yet Travis has achieved exactly
that he has excelled in every aspect of
life he is an author a business owner
the founder of a powerful charity
organization a speaker and a devoted
family man he is a recognized source of
laughter and light to all who encounter
him
without question Travis Mills has turned
tragedy into Triumph and victimhood into
victory in the Game of Life Travis Mills
is the Undisputed
champion and that right there is an
excerpt from the
forward which I had the honor of writing
to a new book which is called Bounce
Back 12 Warrior principles to reclaim
and re-calibrate your life which is
written by Travis Mills the man
himself Travis has been on this podcast
before over six years ago actually
episode 90 where we discussed his first
book which is called tough as they come
and if you haven't read that book or
listen to that podcast go listen to that
podcast and read that book to learn
about the life of Travis Mills where he
came from what he went through but if
you want to learn how he got through it
and what he learned from it and the
principles that he has to pass on then
get this book bounce back we can all
learn so much from Travis and it is an
honor to have him here with us tonight
to discuss his life and some of these
Lessons Learned
Travis I mean that was so good I don't
know what I should say because you
always I mean it's impressive I'm over
here with goosebumps thinking like man
this guy sounds awesome whoever he
whoever he's reading about what a cool I
mean I want to know that guy hey I'll
tell you what man to be honest with you
I I almost never talk in like absolute
terms think about it you know it's
really difficult to say someone is the
most inspirational person you've ever
met in your life I don't throw those
things out there lightly but this the
truth man like I have never met anyone
that inspires me as much as you do and
and so like I said I I I don't speak in
those terms if you listen to CL I'm
always very careful you know cuz when
you say someone's like the best you're
basically dissing everyone else like if
I'm doing Jiu-Jitsu with someone and
they're really really good they might
even be a world champion I'll still be
like careful about saying oh they're the
best person I've ever trained with
because then there's some other people
oh you know what I mean I mean I did I I
and I appreciate that because obviously
you wake up every day and look in the
mirror at yourself and I mean everybody
gets motivated even my w my my wife
today she uh before we flew out here to
Old californiaa um she took a picture of
her watch it was it it was 4:54 she goes
who am I Joo um she's a little late but
either way no I appreciate that and I'll
tell you um I'm pretty good at Jiu-Jitsu
myself I was at the camp I started on
the white belt mat day one you know not
knowing what I was doing and by day two
I was on the black though so I mean it's
a pretty big deal how did you feel have
you kept training uh I I went uh one
other time just because of scheduling I
plan on going next no not next week no
no maybe next Wednesday but um no I do
was it fun it is fun but what I you know
there were some people one one guy in
particular did not like when I tapped
him out um he actually was pretty upset
and I saw him the other time went in
train and he wouldn't really make eyd
contact with me but he was upset and I
get it cuz I'm handicapped but what
people don't realize is like we used to
do ground fighting tactics like three
days a week in in when I was in the
military so like I understand the
concept and um with me it's so hard you
either got to choke me out you know what
I mean yeah it's not you're difficult to
leg lock yeah you're difficult to arm
lock yeah you got to choke you you know
what I what I realized when we were
talking was for you to do exercise is
like there's only so many limited moves
that you can do and so like doing
Jiu-Jitsu you totally were doing
Jiu-Jitsu I mean and that's got to be so
much more fun than the kind of normal I
mean for me Jiu-Jitsu is more fun than
running more fun than swimming it's more
fun than lift it's more fun than any
Echo Charles corre support it's more fun
than any form of exercise yeah yes oh
definitely and I I used more muscles I
haven't used in years dude you sore the
next day yeah but I was like playing it
off like I don't sore you know I'm like
oh let's go again I'm ready but then
then I go to Pete's and where he trains
in his gym there he has a he's like I
want to feel like it's Brazil so the
doors are closed the windows are close
he's probably had the I think he had the
heat on pumping humidity in the air
somehow and then he plays did he play
Brazilian oh he did and I'm like and I'm
like okay how do I get more air in my
lungs like I was going against uh Ian
yeah I got to the point where I'm like
Ian you're not going to tap me but I'm
but I'm telling you right now like I
can't breathe like I'm going to need to
take a minute here yeah that's tapping
by the way yeah just saying counts I
understand that I'm just saying he
didn't choke me he didn't choke me out
but you're right you're right and then
and then like I I spent like $50,000 on
a brand new gym at my house got a sauna
my wife's got a pelaton I got a tonal
machine and let me tell you something
the two times I've worked out in there
for the for the gram those posts have
went very well so you know what I'm
saying like do it for the
gram and for my health I need to do it
for my health yeah no it's it's awesome
and uh I know you were an athlete again
go listen to podcast 90 if you were if
you haven't or get the book uh uh tough
as they come because you were an athlete
growing up and like you it's real
obvious that you were an athlete growing
up when you train when I trained with
you like when I trained jiujitsu with
you you can just feel you have like
you're strong as hell and you the way
you move is like a little crazy and I
think I actually punched you with my
left uh my left Pro or U my nub if you
and your eyes went like red I was like
oh sh this is how I died because the way
you snap from like oh yeah try this and
then to like I'm going to eat you um it
scared me I'm not going to lie I was
like oh I'm so sorry and you see the
film actually they had the video where
I'm like I'm sorry you just keep going
I'm like I just punched him right in the
forehead that's the way Jiu-Jitsu is
jiujitsu is a full contact Evolution
like you're going to get you're going to
get jacked you're going to get punched
you're going to get hit in the face
headbutted like everything's going to
happen and it's just kind of the way it
is and I mean I just got my little arm
like a little bone there that secret
weapon I love it yeah you definitely
have some techniques to develop cuz like
in Eko like in his arm his shorter arm
there's like a bone in there yeah and
it's it's like it's like having an elbow
at the end of your arm or something like
that so when you grind it in there it
was not it didn't feel good I'll say
that it's I did I show you when you were
there or no did I put did I push it into
your
no know you will but it's uh it's it's
some form of ho that like when your bone
breaks it like grows funny and they were
supposed to like it grew so hard I mean
so pointed that it was bruising my skin
from the inside out when I was putting
my left or my right prosthetic arm on
and then they wanted to like cut you
open and grind it down right right and
it would took me out of my recovery for
like 2 weeks or or something like that
and I said no I can't do that so my
buddy was like just hit it on the table
and it CH the bone so I just like hit it
on the table repeatedly for like 45
minutes until finally I was like I think
I might have rounded it up and I did it
I mean it rounded out enough like it
doesn't bother me anymore where are the
chips they just float around I think in
there just got
consumed so we were talking before you
hit record like your reason behind
writing this book 12 I didn't did I read
the 12 Warrior principles to reclaim
okay so that's like the subtitle 12
Warrior principles to reclaim and
recalibrate your life
which can we say you took that from
Jordan Peterson who had like the number
like the best selling book for this is
the second time I heard this today and I
was like I don't even read books so I
have no idea if that's what they did um
because I didn't pick that um the
publisher was like Hey we're going to do
this and I was like that's what you
think but I don't know who that guy even
is okay and here's the thing like I
should because it's embarrassing because
I'm the drive down my buddy Max who
lives in Tula m he's a par Olympian like
um in track and field and uh Navy um
Corman and I called him up to see how
far he was away and whatnot he goes did
you uh you steal that I'm like I don't
know what you're talking about he goes
okay and I'm like no seriously I don't
like read books like if it's not audible
so like now I feel embarrassed where I'm
like well well not only did you write a
book called 12 rules for life he wrote
another book that's called 12 more rules
well this is yeah well did he cover the
the you know what I have idea I didn't
do that but I mean look the cool thing
is uh he would like he he would love
this book um so we'll I I'll I'll send
him a copy of this thing so I don't get
mad at me cuz I didn't I didn't know he
existed before that's probably would he
be more mad about yeah but just cuz I'm
not a learned man he's been one of the
most uh covered figures in the news for
the past like five five years yeah right
right right yeah we had him on this
podcast he's been on a few times the
first time he was on he wasn't really
popular yet yeah and so you know he came
on and it was sort of like cool um he
wasn't quite then then after that one he
just went red her he did an interview
with a BBC MH and this woman was kind of
questioning him and he was just kind of
calm cool and collected and and she kept
saying um so you're saying and she would
like take his words and kind of try and
make him sound a little bit different
and he he was like no I'm not saying
that and it was just it really was a it
was an interesting interview to watch
and it and it got tens of millions of
views and then his book came out and
then it just all went crazy and he
became like a really really popular guy
he's a super nice guy he's even to this
day like he's a super nice guy he's
always been cool to me he's been cool to
us the whole time like he didn't change
like when he became from just like a
normal kind of person to
a he's got to be the most famous
psychologist Eko yeah I mean I I mean
before this book comes out November 7th
but your comes out but uh so so here's
the thing like I yeah I don't know I
didn't know this coming down I catch
your guys' podcast when I can when I
have time to drive but usually it's a
lot of windshield time so I catch the
ones that I can but I don't I don't read
a lot just like flipping pages is hard
for me and it's like a total excuse I
know that do you do audiobooks or
something I I do I catch them audio
books I listened to uh this book of
stream ownership I did heard that one
was good yeah oh real good real good
they got there's two guys that narrate
they're just fantastic um but I do a lot
of audio books just because it's I I
can't like flip pages that well and I
mean I know it sounds soft to me like I
probably could figure it out but but
then I don't know reading puts me to
sleep yeah reading I read because I have
to read sometimes I want to read but
like when I was growing up I didn't read
barely anything like when I was in high
school and stuff I didn't I didn't read
barely anything I I don't think I
completed a book in high school I read
one I read one when I was do you
remember what it was oh I do what Where
the Red Fern Grows and let me tell you
something I want to ruin it for
everybody but I'm going to when those
dogs died it wrecked me I walked across
the hall to my sister's room full tears
Dan little and
died are you kidding me and I quit
reading B what the book about I don't
know what the book is about uh like
Backwoods something they like they're
like
uh they're is it about dogs is it like
is it about humans or is like the dogs
are like no no no it's humans then these
two dogs are like hunting dogs can they
talk and stuff like that no I don't
think I don't remember it was fifth
grade but I do remember like I'm done
reading like this just ruined me I'm out
you know what I mean like if you read my
first book you're going to find out I
got blown up you know it's sad I I
didn't see it coming but you know it's
weird being 36 now cuz I got two feet in
the grave you know what I mean but like
I mean sorry you were yeah I was you
know just reviewing like I said I
reviewed we reviewed the the first book
I listened to when you were on the
podcast again and yeah you were 25 when
you got blowed up yep yep and I didn't
even see it coming I know I mean I
always thought I'd retire from the
military but I didn't know I could just
do it that fast
very do not pass go go straight to
medical retirement yeah just there just
there I just you know I want it I got it
you
know uh so going back to the question
that I veered off on what was kind of
the reason that you ended up writing
this book you were saying this because
people would ask you like dude how do
you basically which I could see you
probably could ask that thousands of De
like how do you do it man yeah oh my
gosh I mean the worst yeah people always
like how do you do this or like I I
don't know like how you're so able to
like how you're able to just be so you
know cool with it and you know and I was
always like well I have to you know like
real simple to the point like I have to
it's kind of like um and this you know V
or not but like at my Foundation there
we bring out the um sounded very very
Minnesota right there at my Foundation
there but I didn't mean to but um we we
did the veterans that have been through
you do do you yeah oh don't you know so
we but we bring out the veterans and
their families uh physically injured
veterans and we show them I do things
adaptly but everybody's always like what
do you do for post-traumatic stress and
I was like uh well there's these two
programs that I highly recommend home
base and warrior path and they have
their own thing set up blah blah blah
well we became a chapter of warrior path
program so we offer it now and when
people were asking me like how do you do
it like this would be miserable and blah
blah blah I'm like well I have to and I
was like maybe I should break that down
mhm and not only break it down because I
feel like a lot of
times uh people will look at me like oh
my gosh well I have this going on but
there's nothing compared to your
situation and I got to remind them like
your biggest problem is your biggest
problem you know what I mean you can't
compare what happened to me to what
you're going through so I took stories
of um you know drug addiction uh there
was a sexual assault like a child sexual
assault case there was um a widower
cancer survivor things like that people
go go through every day um a house fire
and a divorce and how they got to the
very bottom and then how they like
climbed their way back out and then
because I had a collaborative author um
Kathy Huck who's a research author she
went and found the medical because I
said you know there there's got to be
medical research and theories on why
your mind does this or your brain's able
to think a certain way so we put those
at the end of the chapters that we um
had in there yeah no that was clever how
you got someone that wasart smart to
help you in this book cuz you know I I I
um I I left college cuz I couldn't I
just couldn't focus on the whole school
workor but then I found as long as I get
blown up and I look handicapped and
people are like oh my gosh he can walk
and talk that's amazing I can find
someone to do the work for me you know
Guilt Trip them into oh yeah that's all
my I get pulled over all the time I'm
like Oh my foot got stuck I'm sorry I
just couldn't feel it you know heck the
state troopers in Maine gave me my own
bad like I got my own badge what are you
driving you driving a are you driving a
Bronco I have the Bronco um is that
thing like a raptor Bronco or is it a
regular no they didn't have the Raptor
Bron when I bought it so but it's it's
all you know the wild wild tracks and
Sasquatch dance it's alled up it's
awesome I like it and I drive that just
in the and you know it's going to sound
bougie but I only drive in the summer I
don't want to get it like I don't want
to get it like um any salt on it so I
drive it with the top off and here's a
dumb thing I know we're veering here the
dumb thing is I waited they were like
hey for the 2021s we can get you a soft
top not a hard top I'm like I want the
hard top that's what I put in for and
I'm going to wait so I got the hard top
and then I take the doors and top off
all summer long so I don't even use it
and then when the winter comes I have a
I have a Yukon that I drive a older
Yukon I got American flag Grill in it
all blacked out it's tinted illegally
but again I got that special badge in my
registration I keep inside the badge
that the state troopers gave me so I'm
like oh it's in here if you can just
find it in
there I mean get out jail free card
Monopoly is a game but this is my life
you know freaking awesome sorry um all
right so let's let's let's let go into
the book a little bit and um start with
this section here you say we all have a
moment in our lives we'll never forget a
moment that completely changes our
life's trajectory for me it was not the
blistering hot day in Afghanistan on
April 10th 2012 when I dropped my
backpack and invertedly set off an IED
intended for a
truck it was not the day that nearly
killed me and left me seriously injured
although I will say that day was a
really really bad day at the office no
my moment came some 18 months later
sitting alone at my in-law's bedroom on
a small Texas ranch as I sat on the edge
of the bed I looked at a young Soldier
staring back at me from a small sterling
silver picture frame sporting a bright
orange baseball hat and a toothpaste
adworthy smile the soldier stood proudly
in uniform flanked by his Squad grinning
in the Afghan
Sun that Soldier was me US Army staff
sergeant Travis Mills of the 82nd
Airborne Division the picture was only
taken two years earlier but it might as
well have been another lifetime I was no
longer that man in the image and never
would be again that was the moment I
felt helpless enraged despondent afraid
all at once and we all have those
moments I had a hard realization my
military days were over and I would
never wear a uniform again I would never
give orders to my men again I would not
fight for my country again I was no
longer staff sergeant Travis Mills
serving on his third tour of Duty in
Afghanistan in the Army everything had
been laid out for me there was always a
clear Mission and a throw uh strategy to
execute it I always knew what I needed
to do and how to get it done now it was
all just so
unknown I know I am not supposed to
admit this especially as a former member
of the 82n Airborne but my eyes welled
up I blubbered between deep gulps of air
trying to catch my breath luckily my
wife Kelsey walked in at that moment I
used what was left of my right arm to
wipe my eyes as she sat down next to me
as soon as I as soon as she saw my
blotchy face she looked into my eyes and
rubbing my back reassured me everything
is going to be okay we have each other
and you know we can get through anything
it's all going to be fine she didn't say
much else she didn't have to just being
there helped I knew she was right Kelsey
and my daughter had been with me every
step of the way while I recovered at
Walter Reed Army Medical Center my
parents her parents and my extended
family were also so supportive my fellow
soldiers had my back and still do I knew
I was one of the lucky ones there were
plenty of fellow soldiers who didn't get
to go home there were others who had
made it but didn't have the kind of
support that I had some still carried
the weight of War which seemed nearly
impossible to get past in that moment in
Kelsey's arms I made the conscious
decision not to let the enemy win I had
to grieve for that person in the picture
or I couldn't move forward I thought
okay I am no longer that Travis that's
the old Travis the Whiteboard has been
erased I have a pen in my hand and I can
totally start a new I began to see life
as two choices you move move forward or
backward what I wanted in my life was in
front of me not the one in that photo
anymore though the man in that photo was
gone to me the choice was clear damn if
I don't hate that I will never feel the
skin of my wife's hand in mine or throw
my son in the air to catch him but there
was only one direction to go and that
was
forward you know what what what struck
me about that is I mean you have such a
clear distinct moment where you talk
about that but like that's it's where
we're all at like everyone we're all at
this point where we we you have to go
forward you can't wish for what was and
what could have been and would have
should have could have that stuff
doesn't help and doesn't move you
anywhere MH you had that like distinct
moment
um boom you know and and my thing is I'm
always a guy telling jokes Mak people
feel comfortable I'm always having a
good you know good laugh and at the
hospital um I became a mentor right I
was an older guy at 25 I was an old guy
I got injured I was a staff sergeant lab
of privates and you know when I was in
the service I had to clear this is my
job my role people look up to me um when
I got injured this is my job my role
people look up to me I wanted to retire
I fought to retire I wanted to get out
there as quick as possible you know with
within the means of like I can do
everything that I need to be able to do
required to do but it's time to move on
and then I did and I got home and that
picture was up there and I never I I
mean this is honestly this is the first
time I've talked about like this book
coming out was the first time I've
talked about this moment cuz I never
showed that side of me I don't know why
you know everybody think like oh it's
okay whatever but but no Kelsey walked
in and I was just just tears just down
my face and I was like I'm just not that
guy I'm no longer staff sergeant Travis
Mill's leader of combat soldiers you
know best job I ever had and um and I
just didn't know what I was going to do
and you know I I I wanted to retire um
the military good bad or different
people hear on the news are in in all
the stuff but the VA like I I have a
very very you know well um taken care of
like plan of care and and I have a
pension and things like that so like I'm
I'm good and I appreciate that but just
I was lost I was lost um completely and
I didn't know what I was going to do and
and you know luckily I mean I had some
sort of foundation of okay well we
started the foundation we have speaking
that's starting to pick up for me and my
documentary was being done by Reese and
Katie Norris and Reese was there helping
me along as well as my father-in in-law
who works with me every day and we lived
in my in-laws cuz our house in Maine
wasn't built yet but but yeah I um I
play it off as you know we joke we have
fun but when you think back I'm like you
know even taking a step further like I'm
always like oh yeah 19 months I
recovered at Walter Reed and then I was
like out it's like that 19 months there
were some days that were terrible you
know the first day I walked was great
second day I tried to walk I couldn't I
fell over my legs cramped up I was my
muscle spasmed and I couldn't move and I
felt so defeated that day and then you
know after 19 months of being at Walter
Reed and then you forget so and I'm not
sure if you guys have that in your life
where you forget the tough times oh
you're like oh yeah no that was terrible
but it's like I can remember just
sitting at the end of the bed saying
like who am I and what am I doing you
know and and this is I mean maybe on top
maybe not I had a lady that came up to
house sit across a lake from us at the
foundation and her friend was like hey
you know what by the way you're a
traveling nurse but you should know
there's a guy over here who's in the
service he lost both arms and legs and
he he's made something out of it and she
goes what who who's this guy and the
nurse was very excited like very like
over the top like who is this and she
goes his name's Travis Mills but here's
a picture of him and she recognized the
diamonds on my arm she worked on me in
Afghanistan D and now she has moved up
she's a volunteer and I've had her speak
a few times you know for the foundation
and she's admitted openly she's
embarrassed about it but she admitted
openly when she was working on Me on the
table she was in her head saying like
why don't we let him die die he can die
with some dignity and it's the same
thought I had when I woke up in the
hospital I was like you know this is my
Lieutenant Dan right my moment like why
didn't I just die how is this going to
be better but then I get out of the
hospital I met every requirement they
put in front of me to retire and it's
time to go on with my life okay you're
out go forth and do something you know
good stuff and I don't know what I'm
going to do and it was a it was a hard
realization of like okay I've done
everything the military needs of
me now what now what you know yeah and
it's interesting I was just thinking
about uh by chance this part of the book
is in the forward of the book it's not
chapter one it's in the forward and it's
like the lesson is you have to be moving
forward you you have to be like thinking
about where am I going to go now and you
know I'm always talking to guys that are
getting out of the military and you got
to find your next mission right and so
this is a classic case cuz when you're
in Walter Reed have a mission it's like
oh I'm going to freaking learn to walk
I'm going to get on my big legs I'm
going to do you got had a mission every
single day you're trying to get
something done and then all of a sudden
you did it all yeah and you're like okay
you're out you're retired out of the
military what are you going to do now
you going to become I relied on my
military training cuz when I was
becoming an NCO they said what's the job
of an NCO not commissioned officer and
it's to provide purpose and Direction
and I forgot that right somewhere along
the way I forgot that I need to have my
own purpose and Direction and then
slowly but surely after I got out and
retired was at my in-law's house for the
3 months then been to Michigan for 3
months um just trying to escape the hot
summer you know and then moved up to
Maine to our house I had to find my
purpose and my direction I was going to
go and um and I mean luckily luckily I I
you know was able to you know kind of
rely on a lot of my military training
for that stuff just like the mindset
stuff they teach you and and things like
that get some all right um now we're
going to roll into these principles a
little bit and again get there's this
book is I'm going to read
like a few little tiny sections of the
book the book is got all kinds of like
you said there's a lot of stories in
here that you've people that you've met
people that have overcome things similar
to yours and you kind of you align and
explain what they did to get through
something how you did that thing to get
through it and then you've got this sort
of uh what is the academic side
explaining why that's happening so it's
an outstanding book to explain these
principles give multiple examples and
then and then tell why it's happening so
it's an awesome book did a great job uh
the the the woman that helped you did a
really good job oh yeah yeah I tell you
what though research authors they are
very thorough yeah like I I literally
hired a PR firm for like oh yeah we're
having a book I'm H PR firm with some of
the advance or whatever and then year or
two hit and I was like what I thought it
was going to take six months that first
book took like five months I think and
we had it done yeah she had to research
some stuff oh but it pays off in oh I'm
not I'm not complaining I'm just saying
I was surprised that yeah she's going to
be thorough yeah yeah check I wish I
would have been I would have like
checked the ground a little better not
just been like man this bag's heavy
screw this you know pop it
down all right principle number one that
dog don't hunt stop torturing yourself
and stop asking why and you go into a
story here you got a A Buddy named David
Vora is that I saying that right M and
he's got a thing called the Adaptive
training foundation in Dallas Texas and
you went there uh and you were kind of
hanging out it wasn't I think you went
did some training sessions but you you
end up crashing a barbecue there's like
20 guys that are going through this this
week-long workshop and you're sitting
around uh you know having some burgers
and some beers and then the conversation
starts to get a little bit heavy and you
go into this section here it says one
guy named Bruce who' been injured in a
car accident and paralyzed from the
waist down spoke
up quote I just have to keep going
because if I slow down I'll just end up
crying the worst part of it all is that
I don't understand why why it happened
why it happened to me Joe the head
counselor replied let's dig into that oh
no we won't I thought no no you don't I
said this time aloud my Outburst
surprising the group I surprised myself
too I meant to be lying back just
enjoying the bonfire the counselor shot
me a look and asked what are you talking
about there's no there's no digging into
why because you're never gonna get the
answer you want what do you mean I get
it Bruce wants to understand why this
was meant for him at first I did too but
the truth is that dog don't hunt what I
mean by that is you're never going to
get the that answer so why harp on it
you're only slowing yourself down from
accepting something you can't change and
moving on as I live and breathe I will
never know the answer to why I had stood
in that exact spot where there was an
IED buried in the ground waiting for me
it's a fight you are not going to win
ever so why not make peace with
it and and you go on to explain you know
talk more about that but that that
principle right there like people
will will tear themselves apart asking
that question over and over again and
there's nothing you can do about it no
there's and like um and and I have
admitted this openly like some nights
you know like you know I'd say once
every 3 four months not not continual um
there's nights when it's dark and
there's no sleep to be had right then
and your mind starts saying like I can't
believe this the rest of my life I have
no arms and legs like what in the hell
like how how is this something that I
was you know supposed to have happened
to me or why this happen and and you
have those those nights and all I do is
get up and go watch sports center CU I'm
like well this is getting me nowhere um
cuz you're still going to have some
doubt and things like that and some
but to sit there every day and to sit
there and think well why did this happen
could it be because of this did I do
this like was it because of and you
never get the answer like nobody's going
to tell me why I got blown up I mean I
know why I got I mean the bomb was here
right but I'm saying like there's no
Rhyme or Reason to it and anytime I get
thinking about it that's when I'm just
like stop there's nothing to be had here
yeah just misery you know you know what
so I did a podcast a long time ago about
uh Lewis perer Jr who was the son of
chesty perer the Marine Lewis poer Jr
got wounded in Vietnam lost both of his
legs had his hands jacked up really bad
he lost his legs at like the hips MH
came home had a really hard recovery uh
just you know got addicted to alcohol
got addicted to painkillers um just
really had a hard time and he ended up
writing this incredible book which is
called Fortunate Son this the book comes
out it's gets a pullet surprise it's
just like an incredible book we covered
the book on the podcast and then he's
participating in helping with the
Vietnam memorial wall being built and
judging the design and all this stuff
and then that thing gets dedicated and
he's kind of straightened his life back
out and then he falls out of his
wheelchair he gets hurt they bring him
to the hospital he had stopped drinking
and they put him on like painkillers
again he goes right down and a spiral he
ends up killing kill himself this is
chesty puller chesty puller's son who
joined the Marine Corps like his dad
ends up killing
himself I did that podcast and then like
a year later I had another guy in my
podcast a guy named Jim cley Jim Cy was
a guy was in Vietnam he had volunteered
for the Army he didn't get drafted he
joined the army and when he got his
orders after basic and he went to school
as a tanker he gets sent to Germany
like in the middle of Vietnam War they
sent him to Germany and he's like
getting done with his tour and he says
hey I feel like I should go to Vietnam
so he volunteers to go to Vietnam his
Sergeant Major's like you need to think
about this for the weekend or whatever
and he thinks about it over the weekend
he's like look I'm a soldier I need to
serve goes to Vietnam he's in Vietnam
for 11 months last month that he's there
he's um got his Squad out and they're
set checking security and he's checking
their perimeter and he steps on a ll and
gets blown up loses both of his legs
loses one
arm he comes on the podcast and this
dude just lived like an awesome life
like he came home he came home he spent
nine months in rehab learning learn
learn learning to use his wheelchair
learning how to operate things learning
how to function and then goes out gets
his real estate license starts a roofing
company gets married has kids like hunts
just lives in awesome
life and you know we go through his
whole story and everything and we get
done with the podcast and we're downst
we're here but we're downstairs talking
and he says uh we're talking I said I
said you know like how did you progress
like so
much and he looked at me he goes have
you ever heard of lwis perer Jr and I
said yes sir you know Chessy poer son it
and he said I was in rehab with them so
they were both got wounded about the
same time in Vietnam they were both in
rehab together and he
said I accept did 100% what had happened
to me and I moved on and he said Lewis
never really accepted it and it just
tore him up for his whole life and this
story that you tell here like I wish
somebody would have been around to tell
like leis po like hey that dog that dog
don't hunt man you ain't going to get an
answer so it's weird to have the big
smile and I shouldn't have a smile I
have the same kind of story in a way so
there's a gentleman who got both legs
taken one hand kind like lost to like a
top of a finger you know nothing but he
lost both legs and he was pretty bitter
right angry kind of like not somebody
that the therapist really liked hanging
out with and we were out this um this
barbecue one day and I was talking we
were joking and everything and he he
told me you know you know what Travis
you're part of the everything's great
Club I said what do you mean by that he
said well everything you you do you just
act like everything's just so great and
I mean and I was kind of tired of this
guy to be honest with you he was always
just a wher and I looked at and said
yeah no you're right you're right I act
like everything is great because I
realized I was given a chance to live
through my injuries I know that I can't
go back in time and change them and
being you know 25 years old I hope I
have 50 years left and I'd rather be me
than be a miserable sob and not be able
to get over it like you're acting like
right now and you have been all this
time but you've been here and I don't
think anybody could have punched this
guy harder in the face than those words
hit him and you know and again I mean I
normally tell a story a lot like oh you
know I told him this and he was like oh
that's so amazing but really it like hit
him because I I was I was tired of just
kind of his attitude and he was telling
me like everything's so great and I'm
like dude it's not that bad like I get
to be here with my daughter I don't
think i' be the same person that my
daughter wasn't there um and just
letting him know like dude I have 50
years left I'm not sure how long you
think you have left but I'm pretty sure
I got 50 I make the most of it and I
realize the gift that was given when a
lot of my friends didn't make it back
home and I can you know whatever and
then he he I hope he's doing a lot
better he seems to do a lot better now
and we're not like at each other like
yeah he's been to the foundation and
stuff like that it's no big deal you
know but he I think maybe he just needed
to hear that that day because he just he
was so bitter and I'm like dude I would
venture to say that the everything
greats Club is better than the
everything sucks Club oh yeah right yeah
I mean I think 10 out of 10 times having
the attitude of like oh I'm actually
thankful that I got to come home and not
all my friends did and yeah I got to got
to deal with what I got to deal with but
I get to deal with it yeah and I think
maybe you probably have a lot of people
that you know that not put Inspire but
survivors guil is huge and it blows my
mind because it's like you can feel bad
that they are no longer with us you can
be you know sitting there and thinking
about what the situation was and maybe
what you could have done differently but
at the end of the day you couldn't
because this is what happened and I take
it as I'm going to do the best I can
every day not just for my family not you
know not just for my my my my kids and
my wife um but I'm going to do it
because they didn't make it back home
and they would hopefully live life to
the fullest if I would have died over
there in my honor as well I think it's
selfish slap in the face if I gave up
myself because I was given this
opportunity um and it really is a
privilege to like be given life I mean
those doctors worked on me for like 14
hours and they could have loosened up
one tourniquet instead they gave blood
from their veins right into me and they
did a mass call over the PA system in
Kandahar anybody with a posit and
universal blood run to the doors and
they just they had to keep giving me
tests cuz they didn't test the blood
they just needed it they needed it now
so but but anyway I mean Survivor guil
gets me because I feel bad that people
can't get out of their own way and
accept like it's what happened but you
have the ability now to make the most
out of life it's kind of like the Saving
Private Ryan right like tell me you know
I'm a good you know you know what I'm
saying yep there you go get off my soap
box here no all good Eko what are you
thinking there no I'm uh taking it all
in but yeah it's it's funny cuz because
like all these Concepts and you always
talk about these Concepts on the in
these circumstances that are so heavy
you know but then when they trickle down
to like everyday stuff too as well so
it's like interesting to get that little
remind huge reminder that's what I'm
thinking at this time yeah no doubt no
doubt um I'm GNA fast forward a little
bit there's a book like I said this is
like a pragmatic book this is like a
field manual almost of sorts um if you
would have consulted me on the name it
might have even been called the field
manual but you didn't so whatever I'm
the worst I'm the worst yeah I'm the
worst but some of the stuff that you got
in here is like uh this section here it
says are you ruminating too much and you
introduced the the idea of ruminating a
little bit earlier in the book but it
says it says some signs that you may be
overthinking what happened do you Ponder
why did this happen to me and to my
family do you think what if I didn't do
X Y or Z Would there have been a
different outcome do you often wonder
what life would look like if this hadn't
happened happen do you play out the
accident or incident in your head
repeatedly do you feel that what
happened was unfair do you blame
yourself for doing something or not
doing something that could have been
done to avoid the
trauma so again these are these are like
pragmatic things to ask yourself if you
find yourself going down this spiral the
what if spiral or the why spiral you
know and that's exactly Jim cley uh
unfortunately Jim cley he he passed away
uh like a year and a half ago or so but
that was the thing that he said is
like can't just keep asking like why why
me wo is me why me and this is the exact
same message that you've got in this
book so um yeah if you find yourself is
that the second time he said I
plagiarized I didn't plagiarize well J
Charley didn't write this didn't write a
book um but you know he Sor he he
definitely I mean he clear clearly had a
very similar attitude as you and clearly
like made it through with with some
similar thoughts along the way so it's
pretty it's pretty interesting I didn't
really think of that until I I didn't
think of while I was reading the book I
didn't think of it until actually right
now we were talking I was like oh yeah
this is the same stuff that that Jim
surley was saying I don't I don't think
I put a principle in there called YOLO
but I'm telling you right now like
people wonder why I do so much like I
have I I started a restaurant you know
recently and I have uh the marina that I
I bought just drinking whiskey one night
I thought let's go debt decision yeah
why not go in debt and a few other
things and people like why do you do it
and I'm just like well they already said
yolo obviously but I think I'm not
afraid to try new things and I've given
the chance to lift my inury so go after
it um but but yeah I I
just again all those questions and all
that like I don't you know I tell people
my with some of my biggest regrets um
you know I quit college football I
wasn't going to play college football
like that much like I should have
probably played baseball but I was so
good at the position of sideline because
I was there all season and last chance
you if that was a documentary we would
have been on it cuz we actually won the
championship I didn't even get the ring
cuz I'm like I'm just like a like a red
shirt freshman so I don't want the ring
should have got it um and then I had a
ranger contract but all my buddies were
going to go to the 82nd they're like hey
let's just go to the 82nd they're
letting his choose and I was like oh
sounds great so I went to the 82nd 21
guys went to first brigade to Iraq one
guy went to Fourth Brigade to
Afghanistan so I lost all my basic
training buddies and then just like the
gentleman you're talking about that uh
wanted to go
overseas my orders took me to Fort Hood
the big army said hey you got over two
years combat but I had a newborn baby
that taxfree money at staff sergeant
Ain't a Bad Thing to have to plus up my
bank account is a 9 month hitter and I
was a weapon squad leader so I'm
supposed to be the the uh theoretically
the most protected because I have the
two big you know 240 Bravos I'm in the
middle of everything like in middle of
the the formation um not that I ever
cared about that I was actually usually
get in trouble being the first one in
the door but that's because I love to
fight but um but I I guess the point is
like I don't I don't have those
questions anymore my big questions are
like my wife gets pissed too we're
having our coffee I'm like hey so what
do you think we're have for dinner and
she's like are you s dude that's a are
you serious that's a hostile question
it's the same thing at my house uh I
have to like set I have to be
disciplined because when I come home
like when podcast record the podcast we
get done we train jiu-jitsu
uh get down Jiu-Jitsu it's now like 6:00
at night I didn't eat lunch so I've been
like fasting all day come home and bro
there's there's literally one thing in
the world I want to know and that's
what's for dinner you know what I mean
but if I come through that door and I
don't talk about four other things four
other things before and sometimes now I
just investigate bro I'll be like look
in the oven see if there's something in
there what is it can it be P you know
cuz that what's for dinner man that do
this what you Echo you're not in your
head um I can see how that could be for
sure but it doesn't no issue I have
learned that this is just toal avoidance
long time ago yeah oh jeez I we did
there have our coffee in the morning
she's just getting in the room and I'm
like hey what do you want what do you
want to do for dinner you think you know
she's like are you are you serious right
now and I'm like well yeah I mean I'll
go to the grocery store if you need or
we can go to the restaurant it don't
matter but that's yeah that's that's not
a question should ask be careful
especially at 7:30 in the morning having
coffee dude only dudes think about like
what's for dinner at 7:30 in the morning
right am I right uh mostly dudes my wife
she's going to New Zealand right so like
I'm going to start just using the
crockpot I think do you not have a Uber
Eats where you are well I mean it's we
do but it's like I mean I can just go
down I'll be honest with you I just go
to the restaurant oh you got your own
restaurant are you kidding me yeah but
but I'm telling you I love the crockpot
I I'm so fired up cuz at the the grocery
store they already cut up all the onions
and the peppers and the Tom like
everything I need thing with a Crockpot
for me toss it in there it when you get
to do the crockpot thing to me
everything kind of tastes the
same the meat tastes the same the
everything tastes the same in that big
bucket right that's that's spices you
got to add spices and different meat you
can't my wife from England so like some
things like spices are a little bit
unfamiliar I'm going to burn for that
boy
Echo edit that
out all right uh principle number two y
unpack that ruck sack process what
happened so you can grow from it while
when I tell people to stop asking why
something bad happened I don't mean shut
the door on everything you still need to
process your experience and make sense
of it there's a difference between
rumination and reflection as well as
merely overthinking and understanding so
this is again I was as soon as I got you
know open this one up I was like oh what
does he mean by that because he just
said don't ask too many questions and
now he's saying unpack it so right out
of the gate you made
a uh reference there something that I
say is like when people deal with
loss I tell them remember but don't
dwell right like hey man you want to
remember your friends but you don't want
to dwell on it and that's all you think
about and it's a similar message that
you put in in this chapter here about
unpacking The Ruck like you want to
unpack the ruck sack and make sure you
comprehend what you went through but you
don't want to just like keep repacking
it and unpacking it repacking it and
unpacking it type thing yeah and what I
do is actually I tell people when I get
off stage I got two life lessons I live
by right the first one is is this one
don't dwell in the past just reminisce
it I mean I used to you know wake up in
the hospital bed hope wish and pray it's
never happened close my eyes they this
is Nightmare is going to be over I'm
going to wake up right now I never did
wake up from that nightmare every time I
open my eyes I was in the hospital bed
and I realized early on stop dwelling on
it just reminisce I had 25 years of arms
and legs you know 25 amazing years with
arms and legs and then I I didn't have
anym but I don't dwell on the fact I got
blown up I just like you said remember
right I again um that's basically you
know that's this is what I do like I'm
like hey I played college football I
joined the military I jumped out
airplanes and got paid to do it you know
like um LED some of the greatest guys
overseas and had some of the most fun
I'm ever going you know ever had but
just cuz I got blown up doesn't mean my
life was over it just remember what I
used to have and and I you know this has
been now over 11 years being injured and
I've had pretty incredible things happen
since then too you know oh yeah for sure
I mean like being your your guys's
friend Oh you mean eo's
friend okay all right all right want
grab my self-esteem I can't seem to
reach it down there uh going a little
short over here but it's okay that's
they can just stay down there that's
cool
uh little section in here I'm going to
fast forward a little bit again I'm fast
forwarding through like most of the book
obviously I'm not going to do the audio
book did you do the audio book uh did
not this time you had an actor do it
yeah yeah I'm not angry I'm just
disappointed I would I don't want to Bo
I told you I don't like look I like
being your friend you there's there's
something
uh some people have a hard time reading
stuff did you do the audio book for this
one I did did you not like doing it it
sucked I wasn't so you know so I I I I
don't remember if I explained this on
the last podcast um but my body
overheats mhm I get hot so they stuck
you in one of those booths to read this
thing yeah AC had to get turned off so
he don't hear the thing I had to read a
book three days in a row yeah and they
actually after I was getting decent they
were like okay well we got to read the
first third of the book again and I was
like awesome let's just let's just knock
this out and you know how you write
something and you think like okay I
wrote it I know I wrote it I was there
when it was written so I should be able
to read it and then you're putting like
instead of we are it's like yeah so
we're and they're like nope that's not
how it says in like yeah let me try
again so we ah son of a yeah I mean
there's a lot of blooper out takes for
some some words came out it's not an
it's not an it's not an easy thing to do
for some people like for me it's
honestly it's easy for me to read stuff
I don't know
why uh but like I've seen people that
are the most conversational just really
good to go and you put them to read
something you hand them like hey read
this right now and it's just like Lo
brain lock yeah mean I do okay with it
like I can do the teleprompter um I and
I could I could have done it but I just
think that time wise um it didn't make
sense and they they they gave me like
five voiceover people that had to choose
from so we picked the one that I think
was the most interesting I mean I look
I've already said I appreciate just
being your friends so like I don't want
just like hey can you do me another
favor you know that time I got blown up
and you feel bad for me so no so like I
would have bothered you but next time
bother me I'll read it absolutely I got
to write another book I got a figure out
what other thing I can see what
successful out there well you know
Jordan Peterson did 12 more rules so you
can do 12 more Warrior principles I
might do I might do 11 or 13 you know
maybe just go one up or one down and
then I'm just going to do like seven
minute abs six minute abs yeah like Rec
yeah I'm all about the8 Minute Abs you
know what I'm saying people don't real
like this this physique this core is
strong I say right now it is strong I
know that from rolling with you cuz you
you yeah that's like your main body
group urised that the FX cameras that
you guys use for for origin and
everything for the the camp they record
in slow motion cuz I mean I was moving
so much faster than those videos on
Instagram that were posted look I mean I
know I was going a mile a minute but I
was like man those those cameras slow
the frames down for sure it is a little
bit weird like how fast you move like on
the mat it's kind of like a weird like
kind of alien sensation did you get that
yeah cuz there's a lot of stuff you're
not used to so oh yeah with me oh yeah a
weird I can make like a weird growl
sound too
like and then that really gets him it is
a weird thing to like when you start
moving fast it's definitely like you
said I guess it's cuz you're not used to
it so you're not used to seeing like a
body move in this really fast way it's
kind of it's kind of a freak kind of
freaked me out a little bit and and like
uh with The Deco he was saying and his
birthday just hit so happy birthday to
him but um he was saying he was trying
to reach for my wrist and he just kept
coming up short of my wrist cuz that's
not there it's real yeah I saw when I
was watching him roll with you I could
see his like arm moving to grab or like
to underhook your arm and it's not there
it's it's definitely takes some
adjustments for the other guy as well uh
going back to the book here that's right
yeah talk it through there are a there
is a lot of benefits that comes with
sharing your struggles with another
human the biggest being you find out
you're not alone when something bad
happens to us we tend to feel that we
are the only ones dealing with it and if
you focus on the traumatic event itself
then yes of course you are alone as you
literally as you as you were literally
the only person experiencing that very
event however if you change your
perspective and focus on what comes with
experience what you find is that
everyone has experienced similar effects
to some degree when you share our
feelings you discover that you aren't
really alone that realization alone can
lift the tremendous weight off your
shoulders dude it's like everybody's
been through some
well so I traa I got two stories for
this the first one you know like uh is
it Goodwill Hunting where he has to sit
with a therapist he won't talk to him
and doesn't he finally breaks him yeah
well they had a social worker named
Christy that they made everybody talk
you know you had to go to see her for an
hour MH and I went there and talked to
her and we talk about football she was
green pay Packers Fan I'm a lions fan
you know whatever clay matthews's hair
then she'd asked me a personal question
and I'm like yeah no and then we get
talking about other stuff and then we
did it again and I sat there for the
hour like all right well time's up I got
to go came back next time about 20
minutes in I said I'll be honest with
you we're never going to discuss
anything anything of real substance I
said I didn't talk to mental health when
they came in in my room and I literally
gave the name I I I gave her my name
ranking social like mental health came
in the first time I was sleeping seconda
convention only so second time they came
in I was like Kelsey goes mental
Health's here talk to you I was still in
the hospital you know I just shut my not
going to sleep in third time eating a
bowl of cereal with a makeshift arm like
like duct taped like with a spoon mhm
and I'm eating and I see her come in and
I know who she is I saw her last time
and I said oh you know a I if I can
swear you can believe but whatever and
that's exactly what I said and I fell
back into my bed like from sitting up
fell right back and I shut my eyes and
pretended like I snored and she walks
what are you doing and I gave her name
rank and social and she said what and I
did it again she goes I don't understand
that's where you tell the enemy if they
capture you I said take it said take it
and leave or just leave I don't care
like we're not we're not going to do
this so that's my first time and then I
had a social worker as I got to
outpatient and the second second time I
went there for 20 minutes said look
never going to happen said this isn't
the movies I got nothing to say to you I
appreciate what you do for people that
need it I don't need it and that was it
and I got thinking about that and I tell
people probably not the right approach
and blah blah blah blah blah so wait did
she never get anything out of you she
released me no she never was going to we
were not going to be on that level damn
but I got thinking about she didn't go
full Robin Williams Goodwill Hunting and
like get you crying or anything no what
can she do I mean she was a nice person
I said I appreciate what you're trying
to do yeah but what I realized
or
or other side I realized I had a
community of my own and I had Taylor
Morris who's a quadruple npt I had Drew
moly single egg npt and I had bo
Reichenbach Navy SEAL Right double MPT
as well as Josh Wetzel and Andrew Smith
both dou npts and not just them their
spouses and we were all the best of
friends we all dealt with everything
together we hung out every day and our
kids hung out you know those of us that
had kids at the time and and I realized
in that you know looking back cuz yeah
you're right that was I was probably a
jerk cuz I didn't want to talk my
feelings with her I wasn't mean to her
by any means I was never rude I you know
I wasn't she would never later like if
you asked her day she wouldn't say I was
a jerk or anything like that I was just
very like hey look this is not the
movies this is not going to happen but I
got thinking about it and I realized I
had my community MH and it wasn't just
my community it's me and Kelsey's
Community Kelsey still is on a text
chain with all the wies they talk every
day the one lady Jen just had twins that
kid number four and five but her
husband's only missing one leg so it's
like a paper cut so they they're fine
but um but I had my community to talk to
every day and hang out with and go out
to dinners and and and we always ate you
know together and go around talk and
things like that and then take a step
further my alive day I always haed my
alive day you know what that is maybe
people out there listening don't but um
when the day you get injured like car
accident real bad or like me got blown
up or whatever that you almost died that
you live they call it your live day they
want to celebrate it some guys drink
heavily some guys enjoy it other guys
don't pay much attention for the years I
hated it I was like I don't want to talk
about it my birthday's in 4 days you
know I'm fine I'll wait for the actual
day I was alive but then by year eight I
think it was I did an Instagram live and
I I got talking and I teared up and said
you know at the end of it I used to be
pissed used to hate this I used to think
this is the worst day ever why would I
want to remember any of this you know
instead of just you know move on and I
said but then you realize how fortunate
I am and I look back in the years I've
had to recover to have my family to have
have my friends and to be here to watch
my daughter grow to be here um and have
my son which would have never happened
if I would have just died I said so at
the end of it for the alive day I'm just
more grateful than anything and then
Taylor the you he's another quad he's
very dry very quiet and na EOD guy great
guy he texts me he goes nailed it you
know and that meant a lot that he said
because he doesn't we don't talk
feelings and and the thing is with my
community we didn't talk about feelings
in general like oh the socks I got blown
up it was like he just like understood
like we all thought it sucked you know
so we were all just like Baseline level
suck we've all been there um and that
was like my community so I I that's
that's the important thing well you find
a lot of guys that won't engage with
somebody that's not military or don't
they're like they're not going to
understand me so I'm not going to talk
to them and that's why the foundation
the Travis Mills Foundation Shameless
plug for my Foundation here um we have
the path program the warrior path
program for First Responders and combat
veterans because it's LED train the
trainer Style non-clinical and it's one
of the top in the nation it teaches
people how to struggle well because
we're all going to struggle and about
post-traumatic growth you know how to
how to understand what's going on and
and to fight through and to come out the
other side better when you have an
episode or when you feel that stuff and
I'm way off topic probably no no no all
good that's that's what we're here for
but but I think you know with the
community I had I had a solid community
of some of the greatest friends I'm ever
going to have you know and I get to see
actually uh Danielle we picked up today
on the way here um Taylor couldn't come
I saw him from the plane um we talked a
little bit through the door and then uh
um Andrew and Tor are come with their
kids as well so pretty cool awesome yeah
uh fast forward a little bit you again
I'm not going to read the whole book but
it says focus on what's in your control
and what's not in your control let's use
what is in our control to grow from this
is something I always have to refer back
to always have to refer back to like hey
you got some things you can control in
life and you got some things you can't
usually we can control more than we
think we can but there are absolutely
are things that are going to be totally
out of control yeah like the five today
trying to drive down there control over
the five I was so mad I was like oh no
I'm letting them down I'm an hour late
and I was but my driver was so sweet to
take me cuz the car service I screwed it
up somehow so like uber down from
whatever was it an Uber you took down
here it was good times I gave the guy a
big tip like I was like dud I like I
gave him as much as like I tried to do
100 and like you can't do 100 you can
only do 98 I'm like 98 it is Jack you
can't do more than 100 said it said I
couldn't huh maxing that thing out uh
principle three point the finger and
three fingers point back at you don't
blame others but be compassionate to
yourself you go in here you talk about
your program director director James is
that at the foundation it is he's a
Marine that runs a path program Marine
Corps 2009 to 2013 he was like one of
the guys working on IEDs finding IEDs he
he got you know explosions got some
blast damage along the way and I'm fast
forward a little bit you say he came
back from his second deployment and he
says I was super angry I woke up pissed
at the world and that's just the way I
stayed 247 I don't know why I didn't
know why I just knew that I was pissed I
was getting violent at work with Junior
Marines and verbal fits at home that
just kept escalating this among other
things ultimately led to divorce I left
the Marine Corps in April 2013 but at
that point I've been diagnosed with PTSD
TBI and a bunch of other crap and was
forced to seek treatment doctors put me
on a zombie cocktail of medication
eventually it came to a total of 17
different meds some for depression some
for anxiety some for TBI related
headaches and a bunch of other pills to
counter the side effects of the
medication I mean this is just like kind
of one of those horror stories you hear
just getting
medicated uh he ends up start drinking
he's he starts feeling out of control um
no matter how m
he wasn't I was it myself uh I project
anger on someone else I think who am I
going to blame today because it can't be
me and you say that right there is a
victim mentality he ends up like
suicidal um and again this is a long
story that you tell in the
book um but then you say the biggest AAL
moment when was was when James realized
he was accountable for himself
and this is one of the best definitions
of extreme ownership I've ever heard if
I don't change my diaper then I'm going
to have shitty pants that's on me I
stopped looking outward to blame and
started to look
inward could change that
diaper and you know the fun the thing is
not funny but the thing is with James he
actually he's our coordinator right for
path like he's like a big wig like and
uh there's like 10 locations around the
nation for path program and um we we our
numbers are are very well where they use
us for a lot of examples and I mean
where James was at I think he tells a
story that does he tell a story about
throwing a
Turkey um he was at work at a gr he work
like he a turkey a turkey at a customer
at a customer he tells that yeah he he
you could see he's come a long way and
oh yeah but but again yes he has great
guy um I mean truly just a great guy but
he's getting married and they just you
know moved into another a new house they
just built a brand new house um but he's
he's that community that we're talking
about too like he's the one that leads
this program for people that face this
every day y so he's been there lived it
done it and he still works on himself
every day you know it's a constant it's
constantly a recalibration in a in a in
a a focus or
refocus the the contrast that you talk
about in the book and this is really
important I've I've talked about this as
well because this is clearly this is
this uh same principles extreme
ownership you know this is like you
point one finger to someone else there's
three pointing back you it's the same
thing and then you talk about
forgiveness this is again something that
I address and you say this essentially
everyone has regrets for things they did
or didn't do but you can't get hung up
on these regrets or you'll never get
peace repeat after me I am human and I
make
mistakes show yourself some Grace accept
the mistakes and learn from them instead
of dwelling and letting them hold you
back use them to propel yourself forward
in a New Direction Life Is trial and
error there's no handbook on how to live
your life every time that you feel you
may be beating yourself up stop reflect
on the situation and ask yourself what
can I learn from this situation and how
can I do better and the big thing when I
talk about forgiving
yourself uh if you think about like your
relationship with your wife MH or your
kids or whatever if you don't learn how
to forgive like when they mess something
up it's never going to work so if you
can't forgive yourself for some mistake
that you made in the past you're going
to have problems for a long time so you
got to learn to get over it yeah I mean
that's what I I do like my son he'll
he'll do something stupid you know
obviously and I'm like look you little
six-year-old you little
turd actually uh you know it's
hereditary I I kind of I blame myself
right I got to take that extreme
ownership uh uh he's a mama's boy and so
am I but I hate it oh but my daughter
and me are best friends well he's only
six right yeah they they're he's going
to be that way for a bit I know but
here's the thing we went to I took him
to birthday party to his cousin's house
and he had to pick up like the Nerf gun
we brought his cousin he picks it up
it's a big box hits himself in the neck
he's oh oh it hurts and I'm like it
doesn't hurt it's probably unpleasant
for a second you're fine he goes you're
just mean you're a mean Dad I'm like no
I'm not you're soft and then we had a
whole conversation he's like you want is
this how you want your friends to talk
to you if you hurt yourself and I'm like
yeah yeah I do he's you're just mean Dad
get in the car and then you know later
on he was fine but but I'm like I also
my daughter like hit her head at School
in kindergarten and had huge goose egg
on her on her head no Factor yeah she
went out the school calls oh she hit her
head probably should come get her I came
to get her we're going out to the
parking lot she's dancing and twirling I
said do you feel fine she goes yeah all
right so I take her back in school I
said look I know how it looks right I
was in an explosion I'm probably like a
heart ass like my kid's fine I went to a
bomb what was this I said but she's fine
if she passes out or something and give
us a call but she's going back to
classit and when my son he had a thing
at school where he I know he got sick or
something and he just want to get school
I feel like yeah and my wife got the
phone call and she called me and she
beat me there about 5 minutes and she
let him get out of school it comes home
he's dancing and jumping up stairs fired
up going to turn on this and play this
and whatever I said you know what Kelsey
if I would have got there I would have
told him Dax you can come home no
problem you're going to sit in my Yukon
while I go to all my meetings today at
all the different various places I got
stop and you're not getting my phone
you're not watching a movie you're going
to sit there CU you don't feel good you
can go out the class play the friends or
you can come home with me he would have
took option one
she's she's making them soft Jo here's
some here's some advice uh that I've
given to like a lot of my friends that
have kids given it to Leif Leif is super
fired up for this and he takes advantage
of it every chance you get to pull your
kids out of school and go do something
cool do it oh no we're we're in
California till Tuesday okay cool yeah
she's going to New Zealand for 16 there
you go that's what I like to hear man
the kids will never remember like some
day at school where they learned about
whatever but you go do something cool
with your kids take them to work let
them hang out go to wherever like take
them fishing whatever you're going to do
with them yeah it's going to be a
thousand times better and they're going
to learn more I just don't want them to
go to the nurse's office that's what I
was mad about like no you're fine that's
that's that's a different thing that's
that's also like the kids are learning
to manipulate right they're learning to
work the system they're human beings
that are learning to navigate through
the the the you know what I mean
like well if I go here I can come home I
can watch TV or whatever yeah dance
around or whatever you saying he was
doing so just up the stairs just like
going upstairs petting the dog like
having his good old time yeah five
minutes after he got home good smart kid
right kind of oh you don't feel good
like yeah I just yeah yeah you're right
I don't feel good like yeah there you go
kids are crafty but no we yeah we uh my
parents were like every day you're at
school that's it I'm like I think I
think I'm dying you know you're fine I
broke my I was uh out in the woods with
my dad and we were cutting down wood for
the fire and the the tree fell on my leg
cuz I was an idiot and and so I was like
I think I hurt my leg and my dad was
like you're fine tow the sled back so we
had like a sled filled with wood so I
had to like drag it back and I was
crawling kind of like with my hands and
one leg cuz my leg really hurt a lot and
you know I get back and like 3 days
later they took me to the hospital cuz I
was still hopping around and he had a
broken leg Yeah you know our parents
were tough my dad I broke my wrist he's
like you're fine he smacks it and like
he
[Music]
goes I he goes you know what I think
we're going go check that out but he had
to like make sure by just like I was
holding my my my left arm I was like no
I think it's broke he's like you're fine
smacks it he's like yeah we're gonna
we're check that out yep yeah when they
clear their throat like that you know
you know something's
wrong uh principal four snap your
fingers wiggle your toes and get the out
of bed create small achievable goals for
moving forward when dealing with trauma
there may be days weeks that you don't
feel like doing anything you may feel so
depressed and deflated that you may feel
too paralyzed to do anything my friend
that is called collateral damage to
which I say snap your fingers and wiggle
your toes I can't do that for obvious
reasons but chances are that you can the
idea behind it is simple do one small
thing to get you moving that one small
thing will get you motivated go on to
the next thing the simple Act of getting
out of bed and getting out of bed will
curtail whatever you got spinning in
that mind of yours the mere physicality
of these actions should spur a mental
shift as well once you stop being
physically and mentally stuck this is
when you can start to take
responsibility for your behavior choose
to see something in your life that you
can find a positive in every single day
snap your fingers wiggle your toes get
out of bed it's a simple act that can
remind you that life isn't that
bad now now we did we did take from the
idea of make your bed yeah but it was
like you know making your bed like
setting goals maybe you just got to get
out of bed first so like we didn't you
know you made you made Admiral mccraven
you know you made him look bad here
you're like oh hey hey Admiral hey
Admiral oh you're just making your bed
what if you can't even get out of bed
well you went one step deeper we just
wanted to include everybody it's very
inclusive here I'm just saying it sounds
like you're trying to one up
him I can't Snap My Fingers wiggle my
toes I
mean uh sorry you got you can like I
said this is really a pragmatic
manual you got a whole section on
keeping you section on goals and
creating goals and then uh once you have
a goal you need some tips on to keep you
going you got things in here like be
flexible be kind to yourself don't judge
be patient visualize achieving your goal
have a support system and you got
expansions on all these I'm just kind of
burning through them celebrate the
question though so like right look I I'm
not silly like I I'm fortunat know you
outside of the podcast um do you
visualize all the success that you were
like you reach out to Pete hey Pete like
your Gees you want to do something and
you're like then now look at like all
the drinks and all like I'm drinking Le
drink just cuz I like the flavor but
like did you visualize do you do that
like all this ex I mean I'm sure people
know obviously Cho products are
successful and then origin and
everything like that yeah uh no I would
say
this so like when I try and make
something I don't over invest or over
index or think it's going to be
successful I just try it like the first
thing like Echelon front like Leif and I
weren't like yo like we got to build a
giant consulting company like we were
like hey let's see if anybody wants this
information M and then as they wanted
the information like oh cool people want
this information they need to learn how
to lead okay cool how many people okay
well let's hire another instructor JP
come on board by way does it fantastic
job well I've been able to sit through a
couple of his yeah he was in my
restaurant he spoke for a big Energy
company that gives a lot of money to the
foundation and I walked in I was like
Joe are you serious like I'm a speaker
too you know but no I'm kidding uh Joe
perington he he actually um he he got to
do a lot with you when he was in New
Hampshire yeah JP's phenomenal it's JP
came on then Dave like we just expanded
and expand expanded uh same thing with
you know origin like we were making
geese okay that's like one product how
are they doing they were doing good well
let's make rash cards noi okay cool
eventually it's like hey don't a lot of
people wear jeans CU it seems like
everyone wears jeans let's try making
jeans did we buy a jean Factory
immediately no we took a few years then
we bought a jean Factory but so for me I
don't like visualize blindly like this
is going to be great I'm going to take a
huge step in this direction same thing
with the all the supplements it wasn't
like we didn't come out with a line of
supplements we came out with two
supplements right and then do did people
like them are we are they effective do
they give people the the benefits that
we are saying like yep look yep growing
people more people want them then we
bring out another supplement we bring
out protein so doing it in a small way
so that you don't have to be able to see
really far in the future to visualize
for me I'm just looking like oh there's
an opportunity let's give it a shot type
thing make sense mhm yeah but I I'm just
like I visualized like yeah we're going
to I'm going to do this it's going to be
awesome let's go big and my business
partner bill is always like hey let's
just start small I'm like n no I wanted
to build this 200 person Event Center
with a brewery underneath and and um a
tasting room and it was going to be like
$1.6 million project and and then like
one of the guys that's one of the
partners is like oh it's kind of big
blah blah so now put in a little four
bay garage and like about The Vibes I
don't care about the Vibes Dogfish Head
Brewing sold for $180 million that's
where I'm going straight to the top yeah
but we're going to slow it down a bit
have you had any have you had any big
failures yet oh yeah yeah I got one
right now what was your biggest failure
um I would okay well my arms and legs I
lost those
but I didn't lose my ass on it your
biggest failure was looking for IEDs
yeah yeah yeah no no I found that big
success there no um I wouldn't say fa
there's the closing line I'm trying do
right now is not I'm not putting much
time and effort into it have you how
much have you invested in it like like a
huge amount a medium amount Ian I'm not
sure what a huge amount is for me it's a
huge amount it's like 100,000 okay and
uh I'm not too like you know I don't
work on it hard enough that's why I told
my wife she's taking over so again to me
that's a lot of money to put into
something when you may or may not have
something that people really want and
there's only one the only the only group
that can
tell what the public wants is the public
so you know you can make something that
you think is the best thing you know the
greatest thing in the world and people
are like yo we we don't want this when I
promote it and stuff I sell but my
problem is I have a million different
things going so like it's me like I I
understand like it's it's the three
fingers pointing back at me yeah yeah
you know what I mean what's the name
where can people buy the stuff so we can
at least sell a little bit of it maybe
you can get some of your 100 Grand back
well it's Rebel for good well I mean I I
what I did was I cuz Okay so the
military will give you a certain amount
of money when you get blown up per limb
that cap it at two limbs total mhm and
bro what yeah they cap it at two limbs
okay so it's it's it's it's public
knowledge it's 50,000 per limb but it's
capped at 100,000 and with that 100,000
I I know I don't know why that is the
most freaking ridiculous thing ever I
don't know I I'm not trying to start a
fight with anybody God there was some
talks about going and saying like no no
it's not right but the point is as
appreciative and it's taxfree and what I
did instead of buy an Escalade or go out
and buy some dumb you know something
stupid I flipped houses no no I like
Escalades I'm just saying at the time at
the time I was like the number one
podcast in America like able to like buy
an Escalade you know what I'm saying I'm
just saying Echo you have the clout I
didn't um so I flipped houses and I had
some real home runs I flipped Eight
houses um some were just like nothing
just like okay bought it for 880,000
sold it for 180,000 you know like
nothing to it before it got saturated so
then I bought the marina and I bought a
cottage and and I've done Investments
right and I've worked and stuff like
that so what I did
was like two two years ago in February I
decided I was going to bet on myself so
I took money out of the stock market cuz
I didn't like where it was heading great
time take it out Jack I bought an
investment property in Florida and I put
money into this company but I just don't
dedicate enough of my time as I need to
so it's on me but I'm I'm we have a
store Main local store that's like in 17
stores that's going to go into so that's
cool so we'll see if we'll start there
and see happen and if people want to
order something today just to like try
and maybe help you stay a I I take away
from you know what I'm saying bro what
is it what Rebel forg good.com it's all
about so Rebel for good is like here
comes the pitch what we came up for yeah
I don't want to I don't want to sell
anything but Rebel for good is a go the
idea was you go against the grain and
you be a rebel but you do good with it
like you know you uh I don't know that's
just what we came up with so so yeah I
mean I'm not I'm not upset about it cuz
I have another another company that I'm
doing some Contracting with that's that
will it'll work out it'll all work out
which company is that or it's just
called went off out um went off Outdoors
but it's like a I'm doing like
government bidding oh okay awesome cuz
they give you know disabled I have all
whatever yeah I'm more quiet about not
quiet but
like check I'm disabled veteran so I
have a status you're disabled veteran
okay well cool they put on my paper I
mean I'm handy capable though
capable all right we good does that does
that answer your visualization question
it does because I I sit there and I
visualize a lot I'm like okay cool I'm
building this I'm building that like
when I'm on like airplanes and stuff
like that that's what I'm doing I'm like
staring off into nothingness you know
Eko and I just did like a little
recording and I was talking about being
paranoid that I'm paranoid I'm a
paranoid person not in a paranoid like
oh I think everyone's trying to get me
but like paranoid like when I was in the
SEAL Teams i' like I'm paranoid I'm
going to forget a piece of gear so I'd
like check my gear five times and I
would never forget anything I paranoid I
was going to be late so I'd have three
alarm clocks so I was never late I'm
paranoid that like oh I'm going to make
a horrible business decision so I'm more
cous well I shouldn't say that I'm not
cautious but I'm but I don't overcommit
to things so I don't think I don't have
an idea and think like dude dude I just
in I thought of the best you know widget
ever and I'm going to build a factory to
make this widget like we have what four
factories now at
origin but we started with one you know
what I mean and grow we didn't pull all
of our money and borrow a bunch of money
and leverage my house and all do this
all this other stuff to get for
factories in one shot no weu built one
then another one then another one so
that's kind of same thing withon front
like there's a lot of people that work
at Aslam front now we have a office
building we have like we got a lot of
stuff at Aslam front a lot of things
going on but we didn't start that way we
started small and grow and that's what I
recommend people all the time to do with
business is start small and grow that's
I should did that you know here's the
thing I should have probably did that
when it came to like hitting a bomb but
I just Dove right in you know I could
have just took one leg below a knee see
if I like especially if you knew you're
only going to get if you're going to get
capped at two limbs yeah they didn't
tell you that no they didn't say like
Hey listen if you're going to lose limbs
just trying to hold fast to two but
don't you think okay so everybody out
there listening like working hard and
and going about life don't you think
like that's a little bit like even
arrogant for me to tell people in a way
bro I would have probably at this point
written a book said you're capped at two
Limbs and the whole book would have been
about this this is freaking
ridiculous the US government I mean the
amount of guys that lose more than two
Li is not a freaking big number and it's
not like we can't pay the guys the other
50 Grand or the other 100 grand for four
freaking limbs come on well if you're
listening to this and I'm I'm kind of
out some money right now so I mean if
you want no I'm just kidding no I I
believe it's going to like I we have
made some money on it right I'm not like
out 100,000 but I also I realized like
it was stupid to me to not do you have a
bunch of t-shirts or whatever sitting
around that you already we we have some
stock yeah we have some stock yeah
shirts there's hats there's stuff hey
everybody go to Rebel forg
good. and buy some stuff from this broke
ass veteran that's right that over
invested they didn't give me enough for
my arms and legs being gone I was just
trying no no I just I'm not saying it's
a failure I'm just saying I don't I I
think maybe I visualize I visualize when
I don't attack you know what I mean yeah
like I'm like oh hey we're going to work
on Rebel for good today and then I was
going to do it tomorrow but I got to fly
to Vegas and then I got to fly to you
know just my schedule gets me so my wife
would love me to like slow down chill
down chill out little well just figure
out what I want to actually do MH so
like do you know your purpose yeah I yep
yeah driving purpose there's a song
about it and I plan on just being a
billionaire I'm not sure I'm going to do
that that's what you're visualizing I
don't even know why I mean I just like
this song I want to be a billion you
know they're so you know what I'm saying
yes do you know that song I Don't Know
song of course yeah everybody no I don't
know I don't know I just I like being
busy I actually I was talking with Pete
the just yesterday I was driving I was
talking to Pete and I said you know he
said oh man I've been meetings all day
and I'm sure maybe you were in the
meetings with him or whatever but they
had meetings all day and it's been a
couple days he's like yeah you know now
I'm just going to go home and maybe
relax a bit I'm like yeah but you like
work he goes yeah he goes I love it it's
what I do I'm like I'm the same way so
like I call it work but when you're the
boss it's not really work you know you
show up everybody is nice to me you know
I go to the foundation go hi Travis how
you doing I'm like I'm doing well how
are you no one's like hey you need to
get this paper done they're like what
are you working on today you're like I'm
going to eat a piece of chicken and
customer relations you know employe
relations but anyway anyway no I I just
we got way off topic there real all good
my bad all right going back to getting
back on track going back to principal
number five stay within the guard rails
manage your emotions and control your
attitude
dude and you got a a section in here
that I I got to run through when Robert
was in grad school he took an Adaptive
leadership class that always stayed with
him and it came in handy when he's in
danger of losing his job at that moment
over lunch he had so many emotions
control consuming him I really wanted to
scream hey you've set me up to fail this
is a guy that had uh like lost his job
or he no he was he was hadn't lost his
job yet but he was going to get fired
they told him he was going to get fired
he wanted to scream hey you set me up to
fail you didn't even Comm Comm unicate
what you wanted from me I felt we didn't
have an agreement on what I was supposed
to do yet here I was being told I was
failed but I didn't scream I remember
what I learned in that class as the
Adaptive uh leadership class to get up
on the balcony get up high and look from
above at a situation get that
perspective to get out of your head and
leave your emotions on the floor so you
can be more objective and resist having
a hasty reaction going up on the balcony
gave me the space and the presence of
mind to get a broader picture and figure
out a good plan forward there may be
something you want to say but that
doesn't mean you should say it and being
on the balcony gave me that time to
think on my feet and respond the right
way this is something that I talk about
all the time just being able to detach
is what I call it being able to detach
not get caught up take a step back pay
attention to what's going on so what
you're talking about in this section of
the book is like getting control of your
emotions and you got a bunch of
like things to uh that you cover in here
I mean per our last conversation I just
I literally realized it's my fault for I
I don't spend enough time on the product
right now I I detached and looked from
above and I was like you know what
actually as I'm telling you guys this
it's my fault I suck yeah well you also
probably get like emotional about like
hey this is going to be a great product
and you don't take a step back and go
okay hold on a second have I tested the
market do I understand what people
really want cuz you think you do we all
think we do we think in our gut like
everyone's going to love this well I
thought I had some stuff lined up too
where he going to go into a big retail
store automatically and I had it all
lined up and then last minute did not
work out that way I was like okay cuz I
remember telling my wife like hey I'm
just going to bet on myself you know
just I'm going to invest in myself
there's a weird too thing like sometimes
people have and you probably have some
of this too is like people that are so
good and convincing that they convince
themselves and they convince everybody
else that they're right like I have to
be careful that like I don't I'm I can
be pretty persuasive about stuff I can
be so persuasive that I can persuade
like Echo that like we're going to do
something and it doesn't make any sense
so I'm always like checking myself again
I'm paranoid I'm paranoid that I might
be wrong and that keeps me a little bit
more in check about
things um you got a couple things in
here about uh when you talk about
emotions like breathing you say practice
mindfulness which when again this is the
research that was done no but when I was
reading it I was kind of like okay here
we go but then you said here's a typical
initial conversation with many former
Marines hey so we're going to do some
mindfulness work before we work out
today oh so we're going to go full on
hippie ever shoot between breasts when
you were behind the scope of a rifle
well that's mindfulness so you kind of
brought it down for us freaking knuckle
draggers I like I like that you talk
about that mindfulness stuff you talk
about humor using anger as a motivator
role playing you put in there just
freaking awesome something we do all the
time and then just making sure and again
you go into this get the book get the
book out there because it talks about
like the actual ual methodology from
going from like a
negative thought to a positive thought
and this is some of the really good
stuff to take away from the book uh
principle six make the time to be
grateful for what you have and then this
is when the SC you have a little thing
in here it's called you've got creative
it's called science lesson number
one we tend to be negative ncies I got a
little excerpt here it's called
negativity bias we tend to remember and
dwell from stressful negative
experiences more than a positive and to
base our behaviors off of them which is
interesting it goes into it here like if
you were out on the you know serengetti
planes and you watched like your family
get mauled by a lion back in the day
you'd be like lions bad I need to stay
away from them so that makes us dwell
more on the negative than then on the
positive and I think that we do that as
uh just just as our as you know as
humans we do that like we've had at the
foundation thousands of families or
thousands of people come right um
hundreds of families and I I tend to
imagine or I tend to like relive like
the three or four that won't get invited
back out of all the success stories
we've had all the the spouses and and
the crying and like this is the best
thing ever my husband this is the guy I
married he's acting like the guy I
married and I haven't seen this guy
since before he deployed and it was like
four years prior and I'm like remember
that one family that came here and like
they let their kids just ruin everything
they they us our brand new toes W the
kids poopy butt and like just all you
know it's like the dumbest thing ever
and I do that and I and I focus on that
or it just it's it's irritating that I
do that and then I had one comment made
to me when my house got built Gary sne
Foundation Ken charitable foundation and
T Towers were all together they built it
very very grateful to have the Adaptive
home and I had an older gentleman come
out cuz I had an elevator in my house
the elevator was donated but I had an
elevator and the guy said how many elev
how many ramps could you put on Veterans
houses and you have an elevator in your
house he said you're just building a
shrine for yourself out there their
Foundation damn and that like sticks in
my head cuz I've never taken a dollar
from my Foundation I mean I've never
taken a bonus I don't use any of the
money for myself like and if I did
nobody would say anything if I had a
salary but I don't and like we raise
quite a bit of money we're very
fortunate people support and Believe in
Us but I literally go out for two hours
now during a Tuesday lunch I don't even
eat lunch I meet the families say say Hi
and then I take off and I go to
different I schedule other stuff cuz I
don't want people think I did it just so
I can be out there and like look at me
look at me and like just some old some
old guy matter of fact he's a Vietnam
vet and he happened to be business
partners with a friend of mine that I
met my plumber I call my plumber and I
got the guy's number B dude that's a
bitter dude well let me tell you
something you want to see a Facebook
troll you got one in front of you people
give me a bad review at my restaurant
they're going to find out you talk bad
about my Marina we're going to have a
conversation this gentleman I got his
phone number I called him up I said hey
I'm not sure why you're saying this but
we're going to have a conversation about
it how'd you get my number I'm like I
know people don't worry about it and he
just he just couldn't get over they
didn't understand what I was doing with
the foundation and now to this day I
still always think about that I want
make sure people know like and I don't
know why but I'm like hey look we raised
you know I think we're going on $40
million of in kind donations and
donations and and we're we're building
and we're helping and supporting and
building programs out and I make sure
every CH every chance I get just like
right now I don't know why I feel
compelled but everybody knows like I and
Kelsey we have never taken a
a salary a bonus nothing and we're never
going to but I want people I don't know
why that guy just got in my head that's
was like when I was moving in my house
dude that's that's case in point people
focus of all the people that have
praised and been thankful for all the
families that you've helped and
everything but you you think about this
one dude that talks about you oh I
tell you what so case in point sometimes
we focus on the negative I know your
book is correct science lesson number
one science lesson number two this is
your brain on gratitude Studies have
shown that practicing gratitude can have
incredible results on the brain and mood
people reported feeling happier more
motivated and more content after adding
the practice into their daily life so
you got that in there gratitude breed
resilience you give some science behind
that you give science lesson number four
really believe it and you talk about
Andrew huberman Dr Andrew huberman and
just the fact that he's like talking
about when when you go into a what is it
an ice bath you're talking about here I
think so yeah yeah for to really
work you have to believe that it really
works you have to think that like this
is good for me and then it then it's
like more helpful I I should know this
about you but do you do the ice plunges
and all that I yeah I thought so
I why' you think so did you ever post
about it or did we talk about it at c i
I thought I heard I don't really I don't
really post about it a lot no all right
well I didn't mean to bring it up here
for the world but no no there's there's
like a whole thing there's a whole thing
around like doing ice bath and posting
about it you know what I mean it's like
you can do that
um okay you know hey if I don't post
about it did it really happen that's the
question you know but no I I do I I I do
I do it every day I have a SAA and ice
bath so yes I do that stuff every day we
have the SAA my wife wants to get ice
the ice bath or I'm not sure if I can
get out of it though that's my problem
you would need to get some kind of
modifications or something to it but
they're not deep you I can get you
wouldn't drown in it actually you know
what you know what you could definitely
get out of it because I'm thinking about
when I was rolling jiu-ju with you you
have like this weird upper body Mobility
you'd be able to like hook onto the side
and yank yourself out I'm not so sure
it's weird it's just it's just how I am
now but it's
fine it's got to be weird dude you'd
probably like that ice bath cuz I know
you run hot cuz you because you don't
have the like as much radiator as the
rest of us have my blood circulates
faster through my body yeah so you would
probably it would probably feel really
good to you yeah yeah like refreshing it
does feel good I mean you know all the
stuff that you hear about it is true
like you get in there it sucks when you
get in there and then you're just like
yo and I used to not dunk my head under
because I have like real bad something
called surfer's ears have you ever heard
of that I mean I know what cauliflower I
know what Surfer ear so Surfer ears it's
the inside of your ear canal you expose
it to cold water a lot and it gets it
starts to get bone growths and it gets
smaller and smaller and smaller so like
my ears my ear canals are
like 85% shut and so I get ear
infections easily so but now I just like
plug my ears with my fingers and just go
under and it feels really good um but
yeah my son when my son was
like 9 years old we were at a surf
contest and they had a person there
selling like earplugs CU everyone gets
Surfers ear and it's really bad out here
in California and he looked at my ears
and he's like dude and then he goes well
let me take a look at your son and my
son's like a maniac in the water he
would be in the water his whole life and
he he like looks at my son's ear and he
goes I have never seen a child with ears
like
this his ears were already like 40%
closed at age nine yeah I was like yo
bad father coming in
hot uh next principle get a battle buddy
never underestimate the power of a
support system
we have to realize that while our
individual experience May differ the
struggle is the same
99.9% of all human beings struggle it's
just what we do and then you quote a
Harvard
study yeah that's what I I'm I have
three doctorates um I'm a doctor three
times over bats unity and University of
main Augusta what what myum monitors
Jack I showed up for a
day for one of them the other one I show
up for a dinner in a day for the and
they gave you like honor
doctorates you know they still count but
yeah I I got you don't have any honorary
do I'm so impressed bro no no what no
when I got done with the University of
San Diego I was like I'm never going
back to school no no no I I just went I
went for the graduation C no I don't I
don't know maybe I have too many arms
and legs to get honorary degrees over
here on my side hold what you got it's
up to me if you're taking advice from me
for anything hold what you
got uh Harvard study apparently the
longest study on human behavior was has
found that over overwhelmingly people
who have deep personal relationships
with others are happier than people who
don't translation you could be a
billionaire and have all the material
things you want life and still be
miserable money will not bring you
happiness status will not bring you
happiness deep personal connections you
have will it does not just affect
emotional health it also affects your
physical health health one recent study
found that seniors who consider
themselves lonely have a 59% higher risk
of physical and mental health Decline
and a 45% greater risk of death other
studies liken loneliness to smoking 15
cigarettes a
day
check what about dogs are dogs in the
game for that like don't don't dogs make
don't dogs make like pets make you kind
of happier too yeah I hear good things
yeah you got dogs I do I do I got dogs
but I don't have a service dog I don't
want a service dog I don't want take a
dog everywhere BR everybody's got a
service dog now you go into the airport
and there's people that are like walking
around with a service dog you don't know
why they look they seem to be healthy
and you can't question it that's the
only thing you can't question is a
service dog is jumping up peeing on
everything but uh no I have I have two
dogs um and they're at my house my wife
made me uh she made me I went at at a
golf tournament out in Iowa and our old
dog we had to put him down and I was
like you can just do without me it's
cool she's like yeah no so I had to fly
back from Iowa that's when that's when
the Army soldier SL slips out sometimes
you're like I got to put the g go ahead
take care of it I'll be back I'll be
back next weekend so I had to fly home
knowing I was like oh yeah so I'm GNA
land get home the vet's gonna come to
our house and we're going to kill my dog
so cool so like I had to do that and
then um I always joke around like about
service dogs like everybody's like you
should get a service dog I'm like I I
got a dog his name's buddy they're like
yeah but we we can get your dog that
listens and I get offended soz my dog
buddy was so good I used to look at my
dog and say hey buddy sit like when you
want you know and eventually he would
sit down want it yeah but uh no we have
we have a fox red lab and a haves
they're good dogs Chuck but do you think
they help people live longer Echo
Charles assessment that well I hear good
things I've I've heard about you know
they give um people all kinds of random
pets and yeah they get they get like
happy because they have more of a
purpose they can take care of it all
this stuff but now the fact that they
don't live past like 12 13 is that when
they have to go is that a bad thing yeah
that feels like it might beat Jam
somebody up for sure yeah I've heard it
with like dogs um cats rabbits you know
people just have a pet to take kind take
care of kind of companionship scenario I
I think that I think there's some truth
to that yeah feels like some people like
dogs Better Than People yeah my wife was
saying the other day um we were my
family was having a discussion about
like what you would pay to like keep the
dog alive and everything and I think my
oldest daughter who's kind of cold
blooded she was like no more than
thousand you know or something like that
and then you know my little daughter was
like oh no we my son was like dude you
that's crazy and then my wife says um I
view our dog I view Odin as one of my
children I was just like yo if this dog
gets sick I'm going to be bankrupt yeah
yeah no my my one of my my friends um
their dog had like cancer a
three-year-old dog and they spent like I
think eight grand on yeah and I'm like
why you bought it for 300 probably you
can buy another lab you know you can buy
a lot of labs and then I'm like I would
never do that and Kelsey looked looked
at me she goes oh oh yeah you would oh
yeah you and like she was on their side
and I'm like nah you got shut down yeah
you got shut down what was your
number uh look my wife you know she's
going to make the call on that dog you
know what I'm saying same as my
number going to back out of that
conversation real quick and my dog you
know it you know I'm the Alpa you know
what I mean in the house yeah you know
like I get he listens to me the most but
he does like her more let me ask you a
questions cuz I don't I had never been
to your house like do you live in the
country a little bit I know I know where
we're at right now no I live by the
ocean but like do
you like I live you have you been to my
house I can't remember been my yeah yeah
you did didn't you come for dinner no
okay thanks a lot appreciate that no
thank invite I did you didn't fly in
quick enough I remember cuz Le and the
ladies came yeah anyway so I can go out
my back door on my porch and I have a 20
acres with no neighbors so I tinkle
outside that's what I doh but my dog
walks over and pees on top of mine
that's when I get angry I'm like excuse
me dude you know what I'm saying like
what do you and the funny thing is it's
like the little dog first he's just like
a little 30 so he kind of out Alphas you
your dogs he tries to uhhuh but then you
know then I let him know mhm just I
don't know that's a weird thing to bring
up but I get pissed I'm like what are
you doing wait that's a flex right for
dogs I think so PE over your pee I
think dude there was a MMA fighter a
while ago that his nickname was show
enough the master yeah remember that
dude what was the real name oh the MMA
fight or the real show no there was a
MMA fighter whose name was you know Bill
showu the master smith or whatever his
actual name was oh like a wait I thought
he was a regular martial artist like
Trad traditional no there was an MMA
fighter whose nickname was show enough
the master which I have to say is like
one of the top nicknames I saw I saw
thug nasty one again yeah he did yeah
yeah I didn't get to meet him yet but he
seems like a pretty decent guy oh yeah
he's a character and that was a really
good scrap dude he looked sharp and he's
down there he got hit pretty good I well
yeah he got cracked in the eye but dude
he he he looked really good in that
fight that guy could not defend the take
down and dude this is a dude that's like
the wrestling he's doing is like with
chickens right now my boy Bryce dude
that dude's out wrestling chickens and
going in the cage and jacking people up
bless Ty and Ian went out there they had
a great time they I think they facetimed
me actually yeah but uh they had great
time hanging out with that yeah I know
Bryce is a maniac dude but yeah he
looked really good in that fight he yeah
his nickname's good thug nasty thug
nasty well show enough is from a old
movie yeah I kind of vaguely remember
that yeah it's called The Last Dragon
which was the uh black you know how they
do like the black version of a like
movie it's like that's the Black version
of one of the Bruce Lee movies so
instead of Shogun it was show enough oh
that's legit right there yeah and that
part that movie is actually pretty it's
a comedy movie like like Robin Hood and
Robin Hood Men and tights yeah like a
spoof kind of like scream and then
scream yeah okay I got you it's is it a
spoof it's like kind of a spoof yeah
yeah oh it's a spoof yeah for sure no I
don't mean the bad way no no it's it's a
fun movie it's old school though but
that's where show enough came from in
fact I always thought that too that that
name is pretty dope show enough the
master yeah show enough the master is he
is that his full name in the movie yes
if I'm not mistaken damn dude man I was
a little kid when I watch but the thing
is it's real problem if trying to give
yourself a nickname that's that badass
right you know you can't give your
nickname you can't give yourself your
own nickname like
Nighthawk which I think I just took from
stepb Brothers Right Step Brothers he
says like you call me Nighthawk or
something like that call me dragon
dragon yeah you can't give yourself cool
nicknames doesn't work that
way um principal eight yeah back on back
on one that I am familiar with from the
SEAL Teams never give up never quit ever
push past your own personal
best um so when I came up with this like
I My slogan if you will is never never
give up never quit I was doing sit-ups
after I got blown up I was doing sit-ups
and I was 140 lbs right I lost 110 PBS
my injury and I was doing sit-ups and
they were recording me and as I was
doing these sit-ups the occupational
therapist was like hey do you want to
take a break and I'm like no I'm never
going to take I'm never going to take a
break I said I'm just never going to
give up never going to quit and I just
kept like ripping these sit-ups out and
I mean I was so weak I I mean drugged up
looked like a crackhead and I was just
like that's where I came from so I'm
never gonna stop yeah I just say bring
them out freaking awesome man um you I'm
a fast forward a little bit here you say
uh having a growth mindset psychologist
Angela Lee Duckworth is the bestselling
author of grit power of passion and
perseverance in it Duckworth defines
grit as perseverance and passion for
long-term goals in her words quote grit
entails working strenuously toward
challenges maintaining effort and
interest over the years despite failure
adversity and plateaus in progress
people are born with various levels of
grit but Duckworth contends that it is a
trait that develops through experience
one key to improving it as she points
out in her Ted Talk is by shifting your
mindset from a fixed to a growth
orientation
so you also have some tips in here about
how to stick it out don't overthink it
and again you get the book take your
time you keep saying I have these tips
but you wrote the forward you're it's we
now we have these tips yeah we have
these tips in our buddy in our book am I
getting a cut well I I didn't that in
the contract yeah well I I think it was
uh if you would have narrated think
that's contract
check uh take your time always be
curious be a 1center the 1% rule is a
theories making tiny changes that add up
oh we just covered something something
like that on the podcast uh be careful
about professionalism and then you get
the fixed and growth mindsets here from
car another psychologist you got all
these psychologists in here but you
don't have Jordan Peterson interesting I
just yeah well I didn't I didn't know if
he would want to be in my well you
didn't know he is until 15 minutes ago
he's like hey this is my 25 through 36
what the hell and I'm like oh I didn't
realize this is extension uh people with
a fixed mindset those who believe that
abilities are absolute are less likely
to flourish than those who believe that
abilities can be developed in other
words with a growth mindset you you see
challenges as learning opportunities
rather than as obstacles to
overcome that's um one of those things
man you know people that are like that
like do you know people like I know
people in my life where they like
anything they like look at it they're
like I can do this I can figure this out
I can make this this happen that's a
it's a good thing to have oh yeah
definitely I mean I that's what Pete
really I feel like you know Pete Roberts
I we talk I think feel like he did that
too with like the hey we got to bring
manufacturing back let me go get this
old piece of equipment that hasn't ran
in 40 years let me just figure this out
from nothing which is freaking crazy
well I was going to say that I was
thinking about that too when we were
talking about like growing businesses
like origin started with one sewing
actually I think it was started with two
sewing machines two like broken sewing
machines that didn't work you know like
make them work the loom bro the loom is
crazy now we
got six looms I think one of five looms
one of them broke but yeah that's some
growth mindset right mm it's like a lot
of people were like oh you cannot
manufacture here you can't do this here
oh yes we can watch this you know and
and not to like toot my own horn here
but let me sounds like we're about to
beep beep okay so I was the guy that
would always like help somebody like I
look I couldn't change brakes that well
I could figure it out but not like I was
a mechanically inclined person but when
you lose your arms and legs and you have
to literally explain to people what you
need like you have to figure some
out so like for me now after my injury I
have to break everything down to like
how am I going even like making like as
simple as like making a egg sandwich in
the morning not even egg I can't crack
eggs so I'm saying like a ham and cheese
you know like I'm like okay I got to get
this out first I got to make sure I have
this set up and like I never did that
before right I just like run to a wall
and just try like I can't figure it out
let me just ask I I'll phone a friend
I'll Google
but after being injured like I have to
like think every single step of how I
need to do something out before I do it
because if I don't it can go real bad
real quick so you got to be more uh
patient patient and what's that word
like proactively thinking about way you
can execute things yeah yeah cuz you can
get you can get like tripped up in a
situation that's going to be shitty well
I you know it's funny you said shitty
because I wasn't going to say that but
like say I got to use the restroom right
I got a hook I have I got to make sure I
get my legs off the right way my shorts
got to come off the right way I got to
make sure I'm all set up so that after I
take everything off I can put it all
back on to like make sure I don't have
to call someone to help me out you know
what I mean and um it's just like it's
all a process now which which is fine
right it's fine it's like your new
normal I I I talk about you're find your
new normal um but it's just I never had
that before but now it's like I can only
get frustrated so much if I can't figure
something out or some I can't get
someone to help the way I need them help
cuz what's it going to do for me yeah
dude your patience must be like level
Ninja for myself for other people not so
much you know what I'm saying not for
your not for your six-year-old son D oh
gosh oh patience is thin my daughter at
College like I'll be right there one sec
and I he talking to a friend Ashley or
Emily still and I'm like I don't know
what you didn't get about when I said
get over here just gez Dad just calm
down I can do it faster than you I'm
like you know what you little tur this
is 12
it's only it's only going to get it's
going to get worse before it gets better
I'll tell you that much right now uh
principal number nine swim with the
sharks walk with the horses make fear
your friend I'm going to read a little
section here for me the fear of failure
hits home when I was growing up and
playing a lot of competitive Sports I
never wanted to fail and I took that
fear to my military days as it as it
folded in nicely with the military's
hard ass philosophy of always having a
game face I always wanted to make sure
that I led from the front and never
showed any weakness because if I did my
guys would lose faith in me I knew that
if that happened they wouldn't follow my
orders that were meant to keep them
alive that fear drove me when I became
injured I was confronted with a new
seemingly impossible insurmountable fear
how the hell was I going to take care of
my wife and daughter with no legs and
arms who did I think I was because I was
certainly no longer Staff Sergeant Mills
fearless leader of combat soldiers I was
instead lying in a a bed helpless
limbless and jobless that immediate Fe
fear I had in that hospital bed lasted
for weeks months even no one saw it
though I wouldn't let them I wouldn't
let fear win I probably didn't handle
this perfectly but in the military
you're taught if you stop moving forward
you die so even though I couldn't
physically move forward I knew I had to
move on emotionally I used this fear as
a motivating factor to help
me
yeah here's getting into some steps that
you've got here um to help
you overcome
fear number one know what your fear is
is there something in your life you want
to change but don't knowledge is power
number two acknowledge that a bit of
fear is
good it means it is taking you out of
your comfort zone getting comfortable
with get comfortable with being
uncomfortable know that it is normal to
feel this way and many people feel fear
You Are Not Alone these two right here
um making sure that people know that
like that's
okay and acknowledging that it's good
I've had that I originally had that
conversation with guys in the teams like
especially like young guys like you
could see like before an OP like it was
first couple Ops on deployment you could
see they're like real nervous and just
being like hey dude got some butterflies
in your stomach there homie you just
went to the bathroom four times in last
15 minutes and it's like no I'm good
it's like hey bro it's all it is good
like you should feel afraid you should
be like nervous because you're gonna get
getting ready to go out into combat and
I had that same conversation with with
uh quite a few MMA fighters before
fighting like in the UFC where you know
they might have all those guys like you
don't get to the UFC without having
competed your whole life in wrestling or
in Jiu-Jitsu or in whatever and so
they're they're they're feel real
comfortable and then all of a sudden you
get to the
UFC dude it's 100% they're going to be
nervous because it's the UFC and you see
them get nervous and just being able to
tell them hey man you're feeling nervous
huh dude I'm I don't know man uh it's
like hey man it's good that's your body
getting your body your mind getting
ready for combat it's okay well it's
heighten senses too right exactly your
body your mind getting ready it's
freaking it's how it should be um number
four share your fear with others who
will understand what you are going
through number five stop negative
thinking in its Tracks number six
plan number seven call it realize that
you have a choice to get over fear or
not number eight give yourself a big
hyah for going for it now you use the
term H yah why did you use the term huya
super great question for my
collaborative author Kathy okay just
because we know that in the Army you say
Hua yeah say I say Airborne I never said
H and as a matter of fact the only place
they say huah is in the SEAL Teams
they've started to say in other places
now in the Navy maybe that's because
sealed teams are the best you know maybe
if they had if they had a movie out you
know that I would have been able to see
I would have tried to go for Seal Team
if only there were more books about the
Seal team you know what I'm saying you
know what I'm saying I'll get right to
work yeah thank you thank well no I'm
not in high school anymore I mean I had
my choice Navy didn't have the best
reputation when I was looking at the
Services did you even know what the seal
teams were when you were looking at the
services no I was looking at Rangers and
special forces and then I had the ranger
contract and I could I I feel like I
could have did it but they were just
like they were like they just they got
me you and I had the conversation on the
first time is like you were definitely a
way better athlete than I was like not
even close but for some reason I was
like cocky enough to think like I'll
make it through that training and for
some reason you were like oh I'm not
sure which is a weird thing yeah it was
just like they were like oh hey we could
send you whatever unit you want cuz they
were just trying to plus units up to go
overseas mhm and they were like you're
going to go there and it's be 6 months
wait here and I was like we're all like
oh we got to get in the fight right now
mhm I shipped out a week later like like
those guys went like the next day yeah
and then we we still hung out with them
like at UNC Chapel Hill all my friends
and I'm like oh my gosh it's weird that
in 2006 you thought you needed to like
hurry up and get in the fight the war
had already been going on for 5 years
and it was going to go on for another 15
well cuz you know that one time I got
blown up I didn't know the future
uh it's kind of the same situation there
like I didn't know how long it was going
to be but the drill start like you got
to get over there in 2006 bro I mean it
there was no slowing down in sight it
wasn't like this you know 10 foot tall
and bulletproof yeah it's what happens
when you're a young kid yeah but uh how
old were you so were you like 19 when
you enlisted or were you 20 I was 18 but
then I turned 19 in basic cuz you went
to one year oh no you only went well
yeah yeah semester and a half shck I
only have a year and a half left like I
like if I would now it's probably
expired but I only had a year and a half
left for like a degree if I would havez
I did College J I kept re listed to go
to college but you got three doctorates
why do you care anymore oh I don't yeah
no I'm not going I literally had my
daughter doing like she was doing math
like like last year and they were doing
this Common Core thing and I'm like what
is this and it's like well Danny does it
this way and Susie does it this way I
said Chloe cross out Susan's name and
put my dad and I showed her how to do
long division she's like this is so much
easier I'm like yeah so next day like
she got to show her class like long the
teacher goes that's what we're trying to
get you guys to do and chlo's like yeah
this is my dad said this is his
philosophy how he does it the Common
Core thing is definitely strange yeah
it's like have you seen it yet Eko you
might your kids might be too old or Too
Young no so you're like wait a second
just subtract one you know and they're
like well no what you need to do is add
two and then remove three and then
you're going to get the answer of minus
one like it's just real strange yeah uh
I you know I don't like feeling dumb at
sixth grade or fifth grade math you know
and I'm just like nah just cross it out
say my dad says this is how he does
it teach you're going to have a fun time
at the parent Teachers Conference I did
I did get yelled at by my wife cuz I
said Chloe when you go to school
tomorrow like this was this was last
year sixth grade I said when you go to
school just tell them that your dad you
know owns a few businesses he's you know
and in my 35 years of being alive CU
that time was 35 said I've never used
this once a day in my life so just let
them know that I own these businesses
and I've never used this crap ever so
I'm glad you're learning it and kelse
goes you can't say that I'm like
okay I I would go to a parent teacher
night I haven't done it in a while but
when I the last time I went I like took
selfies with all the teachers you know
like with a with a crazy face and sent
them to cuz then my kids were like what
are you
doing my daughters my son didn't even do
it cuz it wouldn't like FAS him he' just
be like whatever you know but my
daughters I took crazy like selfies with
all their teachers you know like let me
get a selfie with
you uh number nine debrief think about
how you would improve show a growth
mindset oh I was going to touch on
something quick with with uh the
previous one when it says like you know
I wouldn't let like anybody see what was
going on like I had my community but I I
I thought it was a Japanese um
philosopher that said like there's your
friends that know you there's like your
spouse that knows your intimate friends
there people how they people know you
how your friends know you than actually
how who you really are for six months I
couldn't look in a mirror at myself I
just wouldn't I I literally would brush
my teeth off to the side because I
couldn't I couldn't see just this little
arm as I was brushing my teeth with a
prosthetic and it was like so hard for
me but nobody knew that cuz I was in the
bathroom by myself when I was doing that
and like I said I probably didn't do the
mental health thing the right way but
yeah I wonder if like the prescription
would be like oh you should have told
your wife or you should have told your
friends or something like that I mean
I'm sure somebody else is feeling like
now you're deformed like I was deformed
mutated in a way I still am but like I
can except this is who I this is my body
now you know but but I mean as far as
like have the community and have people
you like rely on and stuff like that
like that's advice I need to take cuz at
the time I couldn't even I I I didn't
look in a mirror at all if it wasn't
like neck up I wasn't looking damn yeah
and it took you like six months you're
saying to like where you like started to
accept it yeah kind of like okay well
this isn't changing I went to bed every
night hoping it's going to change it
hasn't changed yet I don't think it's
going to grow back and uh yeah yeah I
mean I hate to bring the mood down I
mean I didn't mean that in a bad way
just but sometimes you know it takes Tak
you were talking earlier about like that
feeling like okay this must be a dream
and I'm just going to wake up and it's
going to be over and you know we've all
probably had bad dreams where we like
wake up and you're so relieved that it
was a dream and you're just like after a
while you keep wanting to have that
feeling it ain't
happening and and I was okay like I was
accepting my injuries and I was getting
better I was working out but it was like
just there was different things you know
there's different things like I actually
think in this book in the picture
section like the the picture with the
orange hats in there yeah you know and I
like the picture now but at the time I
was like no I can't I remember having
that kind of go viral with Jenna putting
me on Fox News and and and all that
stuff that picture and my sergeant major
called me and I was in launch Tool and I
said sergeant major I'm so sorry that
picture I shouldn't have had that hat on
and I was out of Regulation I understand
if I got to get a demotion like best job
I ever had I appreciate but I apologize
for he's like mill you crazy son of a
what are you talking about I was
like well that I have a baseball cap on
outside like yeah I shouldn't have had
that on I'm sorry and he was just like I
think you're good I'm like oh
okay never mind forget what I said then
Jenna trying to get you in
trouble um principal 10 a new normal
your vulnerability is your strength
vulnerability is defined as the ability
or the chance of being physically or
emotionally wounded in the military we
don't like vulnerability since it can
imply that you're in danger you're in a
weak position being vulnerable is the
very thing you didn't want to be as a
soldier after all when a soldier is
vulnerable POS in a vulnerable position
you can get killed vulnerable to the
enemy vulnerable to attack we were
trained to not be vulnerable yet in real
life it takes on a different meaning
while being vulnerable on the
battlefield means weakness being
vulnerable with yourself doesn't have to
mean you're weak in fact it mean the
opposite being vulnerable is strength
what do you mean by that well I mean
like opening up like I mean just when I
was saying my my alive day how I hated
it it irritated me I never want to
celebrate it and then all of a sudden I
said you know but after the last eight
years or whatever it was whatever live
day it was I realized like it's a thank
you for all the hard work that went into
my recovery doctors nurses staff
therapists at Walter Reed you know uh
prosthetists everybody that got me back
where I was at
and it was uh a more gratitude of what
was done to save my life rather than
anger of being injured or thinking about
the day I got blown up as like a
positive and then like having Taylor
like hey man nailed it like that man and
Taylor doesn't say very much like he's a
good guy but he's pretty dry quiet
hilarious but you know and him just
saying that like just nailed it I think
it's all he texted me I was like man
that's cool that that we can you know
have that that he felt the same way but
never we never voiced it um
but you know I like you know they say
always negotiate from a position of
strength you know I don't know if that's
true or not because a lot of times I
feel like I'm just trying to be on the
same level I don't want to be above or
like do this cuz I'm in power but I find
myself using my story having to me to
like help Mentor people and talk to them
so like I use the vulnerability of my
story but it's never like on the same
level as somebody where I'm like like
I'm not asking people for their you know
advice on my injuries and maybe I need
to do better about that cuz I'm more of
like I want to be the mentor not the
mentor if you will you know unless it's
you I'll talk you know you two but when
when I'm like I know you feel I sprained
my ankle last week so I kind of let me
let me give you some some advice on
mental toughness right right no I get it
I get it that's right you did crawl with
a broken leg eight miles and then walk
yeah then walk up the hill to school and
back up the hill home with a broken leg
for for 5 days I I heard the whole story
I get it I know about I know that you
you don't know about vulnerability like
I do
bro well I tell you what I tell you what
have your arms legs taken away and have
to uh use the restroom and have the
Corman have to help you every time you
are vulnerable yeah and that was like
the worst like literally the worst time
like the worst part of my life was
having to do like with that part soon as
I got my arm I was like never again yeah
cuz they have these surgers out there
like they'll put steel rods in my arm
and they like it's called osto
integration but I'd be without an arm
for like nope one day is too long what
the what would the purpose of the steel
rods going in your arm be gets rid of
the socket completely and then the hand
hooks right into it and then they just
they do it with the legs too A lot of
people you see with legs like that they
have steel rods come out their leg
called oh no kidding and like it helps
with the overheating cuz I have three
layers on my legs that like don't sweat
M you know like it's up my inner thigh
so you're saying there' be a metal
protrusion coming out of your body yeah
yeah how do they like keep it uh sealed
and not getting infected well there's a
ton of uh medication I think you got to
take just in case so they're trying to
redo the Dermatology the dermatologists
are doing like skin and they're trying
to make it like your skin on your either
your fingernails skin or your gums try
to change it to that but I'm just I'm
not going to but you're not doing it cuz
you're not going to go without an arm
yeah without an arm I'm not going to go
without legs for nine months that's what
it takes usually so it's cool but it is
what it is yeah plus things are
advancing so fast now that you could
probably wait like another two three
four years they'll have some new
advancements well stem cell they're
actually regrowing people's limbs they
just can't figure out how to make it
stop crazy stuff going on right now so
you just grow like the biggest arm ever
well I mean I don't want that you like
Echo over here oh look at this guy look
at this guy I think that's length I
think you just won't you have a real
long arms right after a while the best
so wait so for real they can take stem
cells and your arm will keep growing I
met a Navy doctor that was at um I think
NIH doing that he was like hey this is
coming in the next like 10 to 15 years
and like it's your nerves at your body
damn but I don't know I mean two of the
two of the guys that are quadruple got
double arm transplants so like there was
five of us now there's only three cuz
the other two quit our
club and the arms are functional and
working
and yeah can they grab things kind of
uhhuh kind of they do a lot more
sandwiching you know like pinching it um
I if they're happy I'm great if they're
happy happy for them I just know I just
know replacing nerves or connecting
nerves is really freaking hard
centimeter a month for 18 months and
that's it so like this little guy what
are you going to do this one I'd
probably get something but then I was
like I got someone else's hand on which
really kind of freaks me out and not
talking bad about the people that do it
like please if you're listening and
you're like well I have that done good
for you but I don't know yeah and again
probably if you wait like three years
five years stuff is advancing so quickly
now that things will probably just
improve a ton like I I got neck surgery
uh many years ago and just after I got
neck surgery they came out with like
replacement discs like a little
vertebrae that you can put in there and
it was like experimental and I knew a
couple guys get it got it and everything
and one of my friends got pretty bad
problems with it didn't work out good
and but now like a bunch of people have
gotten it and it works really good and
this was over the span of 10 years so
the Advan is that and things are
improving so much faster right now like
just with technology is just improving
so rapidly because like AI you can have
ai working on some problem while you're
not having to do anything you know you
just like run the run the uh the
protocols or whatever figure it out
they're doing 3D printing now for socket
fits and they're like they fit better
than the molds that they're doing damn
yeah well I mean that's I don't have it
but that's what I've been told but you
might eventually get something like that
you know let me tell you something
Vietnam Vets they come in with old C
legs and they come in with their old you
know body powered hooks like hey check
out this like this hand spins three oh
my gosh look at that Isn't that cool you
want that no what I got works and then I
get told like hey they got this new
thing I'm like cool I'm that Vietnam V
now I'm like no I got work how long did
it take you to learn how to work the
hand so um it took me well I mean five
weeks to get a hand and they have like
this the sensors hook to my arm so I
like have to flex a certain way for it
to make it work work the sensors that
are in Hook to your arm they're like are
they like pads that you push into yeah
that you push into basically kind of
like I yeah so like like a button in
there yeah of sorts uh make a fist real
quick make a fist we have the engine
like on a on a motorcycle so this muscle
right here I have that and the muscle
down if you go down the muscle down here
oh yeah yeah so if I twitch this muscle
slow it opens if I flex it like if I
flex it towards the ceiling if I flex it
up fast it rotates around to the left
and then if I go down slow and then down
fast got it and but you don't think
about that anymore I mean some kind of
but like people cuz I can't feel so when
I grab something like this can I have to
like watch what I'm doing okay you know
what I mean I was in the VA bathroom
like when I first retired and I was
taking a pee not paying attention I just
grabbed right a hold of myself and I
about passed out from the pain and I had
to like breathe through it like okay we
got to breathe this out cuz I need to I
need I need to un Flex this I need to
flex his hand up slowly I I really got
to stop grabbing my wiener at the Ural
right now
cuz I almost passed out from the pain I
mean it was I was
like
sorry so if you like tense your arm
because you're in pain then it just grab
harder and all of a sudden you're in a
real pickle yeah yeah it's not it's not
good it's not good but uh I remember
like in the bathroom like breathing it
out like okay like talking myself off
the ledge like this this uh this is not
good problem yeah I was just having no
one walked in on me talking to myself
and at the Ural like let go just we're
just going to let go right
now that's off the rails anyway sorry
um all right uh well okay so yeah go
like things happen right like the other
night my one arm I I have a couple arms
and I usually put one on the charger and
I wear one and I switch them off well I
had the one on longer than I thought so
it died so I had my arm on with a hook I
have to go upstairs at 10:30 at night
right everybody's already in bed I'm up
watching college football or something I
grab my other arm I go out to the
elevator I try to switch the hook out
the hook falls on the ground okay now I
don't have so now right what I have is
my hook on the ground I'm in my
wheelchair and I can't reach
it well then I switch out the hand I
switch this arm out and I'm like okay
I'm just going to switch it out quick
and get the one that's powered so I put
the one that has a power on I can't get
that I knocked the other onto the ground
mhm so I'm like trying to fall in my
chair like brushing it over against the
wall I got to go downstairs I got to
drive over and get my hand put my hand
on this arm get to work pick up the
other arm pick the hook up take the hand
off put the hook on andbody but again
this is all like I'm banging and
clanging stuff where wake everybody up
but like that's where you got to stay
patient right I mean it wasn't like
grabbing myself like passing out from
pain but boy I was mad and that's when
you're like why is this my life like are
you kidding me right now m but I made it
work mhm you
know how long does the how long does the
power in the arm last for about a day
and a half okay day and a half two days
and you got two of them on rotation yeah
yeah I have a few of them
Jack all right cuz and then when I go to
get them they're like sometimes like
well you want another one I'm like well
yeah and then they look at me funny I'm
like you ever had no hands and then have
one not work and then you need one
because you don't have them yeah they're
like yeah no no I'm like yeah well
that's that's what happen to me so give
me another one so I'll take another
please within the within the
guidelines uh principal
11 serve find your for find your voice
build on your strengths and live
meaningfully
so this is where we start talking about
this is a
um ptg post-traumatic
growth I'm no expert so I point at path
founder and this is p
a Founder Josh Goldberg who wrote
struggle well to better explain how this
happens a great deal of the time people
who go through these difficult life
experiences that these traumas and these
losses often reported in the aftermath
of that experience going through the
post the process of post post traumatic
growth this leads them to report that
their life had changed for the better in
terms of it being more authentic and
more meaningful and more purposeful than
it was before they had the experience
they talk about growing in terms of
their sense of hope for the future a
recognition of the value of deeper
relationships with other people a sense
of personal strength the idea that
nothing can be permanently not the idea
that nothing can permanently knock us
down and appreciation for the small and
big things in life and spiritual and
existential growth the idea that they
are now asking and reflecting upon the
deepest questions that life can offer us
who am I why am I here and where do I
belong along and that's what post post
traumatic growth describes and what the
entire science and concept behind it are
all about so this is just like the
opposite of well maybe it's not the
opposite of but it's a different take on
post-traumatic stress disorder which is
like I got a real problem because of
this bad thing happened to me this is
hey this bad thing happened to me and
I'm actually better because of it and
then the did I not spell out what path
meant in there it's not in here
I found it on your website it is uh it
is Progressive and alternative training
for helping Heroes so that's the that's
the nonprofit that we partner with and
we have the there's like 10 facilities
around the nation and that's for combat
veterans and um it's for First
Responders and it's a week weekl long
course we get a big Grant um Avalon uh
Avalon action Alliance anyway we get a
grant for it mhm and then there's places
all like throughout the nation that do
it and it's one of the best in the
nation um and I live and I I look I know
we have at my foundation so I'm like oh
it's a best in the nation but but really
it is I mean the amount of letters um we
get from either the person that came or
the family members spouses moms dads
about the change they actually see in
the person that came to the to the
program um I it just it just lift you up
you know I mean we had a few people say
like this is my last thing I was going
to commit suicide after this it's the
the most effective one that you've seen
well there's this one and there's one
out of Massachusetts called home base
that I I believe in as well um it's a
it's a two-e program this is a onewe and
then follow on and you know it's It's
cool cuz it's train the trainer I mean
everybody wants to train the trainer
it's people that have been through the
program that actually did serve whether
they're we have some state troopers as
well as combat veterans that lead it and
um I you know the thing is you have to
fill out the paperwork yourself like if
say say your wife thinks you should go
and she hits up the website she fills it
out
doesn't matter this person has to want
to go and if if you sign up you'll get
in but just they're on a little bit of a
back order so they're expanding right
now um I mean yeah and this isn't like
any big secret um I think we're buying
another facility um to actually run just
path out of where just down the road
actually so actually it's it's down the
road from from from the the camp the
emerging Camp okay so we're talking like
three like no not even three miles
probably probably a mile and a half from
from where the Emer Camp is will it be a
year round Camp yeah oh yeah okay yeah
yeah but we're um I we're I think we put
the off we're about to put the offer in
okay awes but um I mean it could fall
through but we're trying to find a
facility so we can do instead of the 12
weeks we do now um at least 24 weeks um
because there's nine days that is total
for the path guides but but we're trying
to do that full-time because it's it's
there's so much need right now yeah and
and they're opening the program for a
few other people I don't think I can go
into that right now but they're open the
program um for for more people to be
able to do it good good no uh just
reading about it sounds like an awesome
program and again you got more
information here in the book about it so
that's that's cool um going back to the
book here it says like I said at the end
of the day you get one go around in life
you get one chance to make your mark how
do you want to leave your mark on this
world the answer should give you purpose
if that's being a coach and giving your
all to the students or being a parent
and being the best darn parent there is
then how can you be better at that every
day and that leads to the the final
principle principle number 12 make it a
daily practice ask yourself what is
stopping you from
re-calibrating resilience isn't
something that you get like a sticker or
a badge and then you carry around for
your life you need to continue to work
at it and you will want to because we
all need it again and again hopefully by
now you have learned that pain is good
and important never never fun or easy
but we can learn from it and build a
resilience for it science shows that we
can develop and improve our resilience
but it requires practice and
consistency yeah I think this is what
you know the the the biggest message or
the underlying message in the book is
like we all have the
ability to get better stronger and
recognizing that the pain and suffering
that you have first of all you're going
to have it you're going to have it in
life doesn't matter you're going to have
it there's going to be pain there's
going to be suffering you're going to
face disease you're going to lose people
you're going to lose you're going to
have to freaking fly home and put down
your dog like things are going to suck
sometimes and you got to be able to deal
with those things and this is uh another
interesting point on that every day is a
choice humans make about 35,000
conscious decisions each day each
decision of course can change your life
in a big in big ways and Smalls For
Better or Worse while I couldn't stop
that I IED from doing its job that day I
can stop it from detracting from the
rest of my life from those decisions you
have a choice of how to react do you
choose to be angry isolated fearful
untrusting or do you choose to be
hopeful fearless and
trusting yeah I mean that right there
recognizing that you have the ability to
decide which way you're going to go
mhm and and you know the thing is with
with the book is we uh like you said we
have other people's stories too you know
people go through divorce house fires
cancer you know we we all face something
in life like you said there's you know
um there's just things that happen to us
it's how we we want to react to them
it's how we want to get through them um
and it's not like unheard of like I'm
not the only person to get blown up lose
my arms and legs as unique as it is I'm
not the only one and I had a guy that
came to the hospital to tell me I'm not
a bad person God doesn't hate me nothing
I did in life made me deserve this and
that I was going to be AOK I was going
to learn how to walk try feed myself and
he was a second ever quadruple a MH you
know um and more over than that he was a
marine so I was like man if he can
figure it out I can't be that hard you
know no good good guy good guy Todd
nicely and and that's the thing like
people have all you know it's probably
bad to say been there done that but
people they face the same problems
whether they think they're alone or not
or they believe that no one's out there
like them there's somebody out there
most likely been through it and you know
that's what I was trying to do with with
this is is try to highlight my story in
my Outlook but using other people's
stories in their Outlook and then like
you said I got all the psych I missed
out on the most important psychologist
apparently I apologize for that but you
know maybe maybe next time maybe next
book the next 12 rules of warrior
resilience you can get in then
yeah uh yeah no it's that's what I said
it's like such a good guide book and and
you're right I didn't uh you know when I
was highlighting what to read and after
I read the book I I wanted to kind of
focus on the principles themselves today
but the the stories that you've got in
the book and they're not all your
stories there's are your stories but a
lot of them are stories of people that
you know people that you've worked with
people that have come through and
they've got their their struggles that
they've been through whether it's losing
a spouse and then losing a child like
you got a woman in there that suffered
through that you got you know victims of
disease people that have been through
you know got severe PTSD so there the
sergeant major that he lost a lot of
guys yeah 20 I think you said 22 guys
yeah um they're a lot more wounded too
he yeah yeah he had he he's and he's one
of our path guides actually yeah that's
like like what better guy yeah to be
able to talk and help help people out
for that and I wasn't criticizing how
you did this I just meant I appreciate
the fact you're highlighting this I
didn't want to be sound like criti
didn't come out cross that at all they
just reminded me you grabbed your knife
when I said it so I just like when
you mentioned that I I remember thinking
consciously like okay there's these
stories that will definitely be able to
show examples but it would we'd just be
like I might as well just read the book
might as well just do the audio book
which is apparently what you wanted me
to do anyways well yeah Sor right that's
you know what I'm the worst that's my as
my wife she'll tell you um only when I
ask her what's for dinner at 8 you know
7: in the morning yeah it's not a good
move don't need path to tell you that
that every day is about control a major
plot point in this book is that you
can't change what happened to you nor
make it go away but you can control your
attitude after all you don't want to
fall into the category of learned
helplessness or victimhood here are a
few ways to Stave off helplessness and
you got a bunch of them here be
optimistic have a creative Outlet get
walking any exercise is good you got
this thing uh practice a Japanese thing
called Forest bathing or shinrin Yoku
which is like going out into the
Wilderness which is awesome yeah I think
that was my idea probably yeah for sure
for sure uh while you're at it walk to
the gym be be grateful like these are
the key components that you've got um so
much about gaining and maintaining
resilience is about practicing it and
life gives us many opportunities to
practice am I right once you make
resilience a daily practice it will
become second nature and with that
inevitable next Crisis or challenge you
will be that much stronger and prepared
to take it on it will be about how to
put the next foot in front of the other
and keep you going always bounce back
and just to close out uh the book I want
to read one little section from the from
the epilog it just says as you finish
this book I want to leave you with this
message you are a lot more resilient
than you think you are and there are
things that you can choose to do to to
allow that resilience to bloom are you
ready to make that
choice man I sound like a genius
whenever you guys do this I'm telling
you what I'm a little bit of a mural
coworker over here I guess yeah I'm
telling you what yeah yeah no man it's
it is it's cuz honestly think about what
you've been through think about where
you're at now like you've got some
freaking Lessons Learned to pass on and
you pass them on in the book um are you
ready to make that choice and that's
that's like the question right and like
I said you're living proof that it truly
is a choice yeah uh our attitude our
perspective our ability to bounce back
that's on us you know so this book is
going to help a lot of people and it's
going to look you don't need to be in
one of these severe moments right now to
be like oh I don't really have any
trauma right now so I don't need this
book a this stuff is effective for as
Ekko pointed out like every day what
like what little oh you lost your job
that's not that's probably not going to
leave like some big traumatic mark on
you but guess what you got to make some
adjustments in life right you got some
things you're going have to get through
uh you might go through like a
relationship issue maybe you get you
know you split up from your girlfriend
if you're 19 years old that can be
traumatic when you're 19 right or you're
getting a divorced like things that may
not seem as severe as like what guys in
the military might go through there's
still the princip in this book are going
to be able to help you out and what's
really nice is when you do face
something that's more severe when you
lose a loved one when there's some
horrible disease that enters your world
you'll you'll definitely have some tools
to work through that stuff and I think
this this is going to help out so many
people well I appreciate that also I was
thinking what is what is your
nickname cuz I was about to call you Big
Mac cuz you're the secret sauce baby you
know what I'm saying that's you know
what I'm saying is that no my my my
nickname is just my nickname is just Joo
just Jo my parents gave me that nickname
before I was even born I know two other
nicknames by the way for me yeah oh what
are they Mothra oh that's an old school
one yep and the other one is uh way of
the streets way of
dang so I remember Mothra yeah why did I
come up with
that I don't know forget what it was
there well motha is the bad guy on who
Godzilla the bad guy on Godzilla but
there was so ekko's brother had a social
media platform before any of these other
social media platforms were around and
it was almost it was honestly it seemed
like there was 30 people on it right
that's what it seemed like to me there
was probably thousands but like yeah
there the like we would kind of all
interact with each other just a small
group of people that I actually knew the
people and for some reason it's true
story there was some like probably some
talking about like being Godzilla
or something and then I came back back
with like well a Mothra it's probably
something stupid like that and then what
was the other one way of the streets
stre where did that come from I forget
where it was but to me that one was like
the one that I would use from time to
time way of the streets way of the
streets I forget might be because we
made that old advertisement for victory
MMA where I was like
uh in the streets I was saying that jitu
is good like on the mat in the cage or
in the streets okay so to correct Joo
cuz I remember way better so he said his
closing line in one of the videos was uh
ghee no ghee or in the streets and then
it says then he says uh making things
work making people hurt that's what Joo
said his closing and then but then it
came up later I forget what um like what
we're doing or what I don't know but it
was written like way of the St out I
think you signed something I don't know
it was like way of the
streets and one time you said uh when
we're going to go train and like um oh
yeah I'm going to be there at noon or
whatever and then and then I would like
talk some trash or whatever and you be
like whatever then I'll see you at noon
ghee or no ghee then period period
period wait for a little while or of
course in the streets in the streets go
the streets so I don't know if I'm
Secret Sauce but I can make some stuff
work make people hurt in the streets
that's right that's right the streets
ofce you know I found that as much as I
really appreciate the ghee that I got at
Camp M it's better be no cuz no can ghee
choke me yeah well you're you're at a
disadvantage with ghee because you can't
grab you can't grab the ghee so you're
much better off Noe for sure yeah yeah
well I don't mind if they wear a ghee
I'm just saying I don't want to wear one
it sets me up for failure yeah now ghee
is not good for you I thought about
going naked you know just like see who's
really dedicated and us you can you can
you can claim victory I'm not I'm not
getting into the shot the old
self-esteem but okay it's cool cool cool
and I've been slim fasting I don't know
if you noticed um you've been What Slim
fasting Sun fasting slim oh slim fasting
Jack no actually uh I I tried to do the
rtds but then I just I drink too much of
them like this is not reducing any
calories well I did like the crush like
how crushable these are you did that
story cuz like I find myself I'm like on
my third my third Joo go and I haven't
had any water today yeah you know it's
like it's 1:00 in the afternoon I'm like
I know yeah to be awake for 19 hours
yeah do electrolyt you definitely got to
be you definitely got to be a little bit
careful on that that's what I find like
I had one normally I don't drink them
like after like maybe
2:00 um occasionally during the week if
I'm coming to train
that then I'll drink one on the way here
but then you exert so much energy you're
just going to be tired but if I'm just
not doing anything and I drink one BR
that's that's basically what I do I just
ride around and do a bunch of phone
calls and Conference meetings and stuff
and I just drink them yeah cuz you know
I I work out for the gram but that's it
you know and then it looks like the one
video that you guys put out looks like I
actually am choking you out you're
telling me what to do and it looks like
I'm actually getting you people like oh
my gosh can't believe choked them out
like yeah I know yeah I know that was
all that was all make believe
yeah um so you got this book man order
it what did we hit everything else you
got you got the Travis Mills Foundation
right yeah you got the campus up in
Maine Travis Mills foundation.org this
is a I've been there it you know I've
met a bunch of people that have been
through the programs you do everything
up there cooking baking martial arts
ropes course cycling horse riding
shooting hiking golf massage therapy ice
fishing yoga archery kayaking canoeing
boating fly fishing bass fishing pottery
painting and snow shoing to list a few
of the freaking activities that people
can do up there they bring out a dog
sled in the winter time let people ride
on a dog sled that's actually pretty
it's pretty legit yeah that sounds
awesome I mean I mean the other stuff's
kind of cool too I guess but uh no I
look I appreciate just the chance to
hang out with you guys you guys are
always awesome and um you know with the
book coming out I'm I'm fired up for it
cuz I I get asked all the time how I do
it and I thought let me just figure out
how I can show people how how I do it or
how they can do anything that's hard in
life because we all have you know we all
have struggles and things like that that
we go through or you could use a little
Guiding Light and I
mean I got tired of just saying like
well I just do you know I have to you
have two choices right the real Oliver
Twist situation get better or don't
what's the Oliver Twist situation isn't
that no that's a r that's a forest damn
it Oliver Twist bro he just he he just
Oliver Twist Oliver Twist he just made a
metaphor you didn't know no it wasn't
Oliver Twist I'm thinking about Robert
ref or the damn it I'm a doctor okay I'm
a doctor of three what wonder what
metaphor you could have been thinking of
you know the t
uh the the forest both PS and the forest
it's like Robert Redford maybe Robert
Redford's an actor is he exactly he says
it no it's Robert Frost oh Rober Robert
Frost two roads diverge yellow wood yeah
what path I had to take get better or
not I Oliver Twist I like please I want
some
more just like Oliver Twist and of
course I'm over here like yeah just like
Oliver Twist bro yeah you know it was
just like brilliant metaphor not like
Annie dude
yeah come on the roof yeah the will come
out tomorrow if you want it to you know
if you let it just if you let it bet
your bottom dollar uh what else you got
going on uh you got Rebel for good so we
talked about that yeah everyone's going
to buy Rebel forg good.com they're going
to go and buy it they're going to love
these shirts they got the backwards
every turn the life around there you go
you can see that you got the marina
lakeside lakeside Lodge and Marina in
East win winr Maine just like a we just
named it Lakeside Lodge cuz you used
called Lakeside Motel and cabins and
Norman beo didn't help us out with the
whole Motel thing yeah but we're
actually doing a a remodel right now but
it's it's going well it's fun uh it
closes down like two weeks we have like
the main building open but so Lakeside
lodge.com but people come in there in
the in the springtime start coming back
up to Maine for vacation yeah but it's
like number one like fishing lake so we
have a lot of fishermen that come like
number one bass like can made on a lot
of charts no kidding yeah I don't fish
so when people come to the office like
hey where they catching the fish at I'm
like in the water they're like yeah but
where like between the top and the
bottom I'm pretty sure they're like what
do you know what do you what do you
catch like what do you I'm like I catch
a buzz on my boat sometimes but like
that's accidental I don't try to do that
but they get they get a little
irritated and and then you have the
restaurant restaurant white duck pub.com
white uh yes it's white buck white duck
pub.com I looked it up sure it's not
white do
BR no I'm not sure but I'm pretty sure
anyways if you Google White Duck Pub
you'll find it yeah what what's the main
deal going on there just American
beastro year round yeah oh yeah 11 to n
every day and um we're made from scratch
kitchen so nothing's ever Frozen like
our wings take like 13 hours to make mhm
we sell a lot of them we sold over
10,000 Burgers the first year this year
we're like crushing that damn and uh we
have Burger of the like we have a only
one Burger on the menu it's not like you
can get like this kind of burger and
that kind of burger it's like we have
the white duck brup Burger what's the
what is the deal what's it's just really
good but like what is on a white duck
burger that is tomato onions that is
tomato onions just like it's a basic
deal it's not basic it's not Gourmet oh
it's Gourmet for sure like how you cook
it kind yeah yeah true and it's made
with love that's the kicker so and we
have poutin so like our number one
seller is actually the burger second
thing we sell the most of is actually
bacon and third is potatoes H do you do
breakfast or no no so how do you sell so
much bacon uh on the burgers I think we
just that's I think that's why
everything tastes good I think we just
bacon on everything it's like thick cut
delicious like organic whatever bacon of
Awesomeness and then yeah and then um up
the hill I own
um well me and some me and some buddies
we own a couple more buildings put a
brewery in and then eventually a
Distillery I was in Arizona where JP was
speaking actually with JP and I was
speaking um as well but I was with JP
there and uh we had a booth right next
to M's Booth we actually split the the
fundraising 150,000 to each of us it was
really nice TL yber put it on
nice and this guy walks by he's all
tatted up and he's pretty buff and he
walks by I'm like hey look I'm not a
piece of meat stop looking at my looking
at me like that okay my wife's a jealous
type too so it's not going to happen and
I guy was even looking at me right he's
like what what I'm like I saw you
checking my legs out okay looks are free
but that's all you're going to get from
me bud and just like hit a conversation
off turns out his name's John peasy uh
Peasley and his wife Sarah fantastic
people he is the biggest independent
Brewery and Distillery owner in Arizona
he has Grand Canyon River um brewing in
in spirits CH he's like dude I'll show
you how to do it all so he's like give
me like the like he flew out to my Gala
he hung out for a week that's awesome
man good
dude oh awesome yeah and he does
Jiu-Jitsu he met Pete um and Amanda at
the at the gala but so you're going to
do a brewery making beer mhm is it just
beer is it like whiskey or something
else or so here's the thing you take
beer when it goes bad you can turn it
within two weeks into vodka Jin whiskey
takes four years for a whiskey but you
can turn it all into that that's people
do
so you can like go to the local
distribution centers that got a like all
the old beer back instead of them paying
to send it back they'll just give it to
you no kidding and then you get a
crushing machine you crush it down you
crush beer you crush the beer down right
so they crush the cans oh okay and then
you take the cans turn those in for the
aluminum prices and then you get all
this old beer and two weeks later you
got all the the stuff made for vodka Jin
whatever are you the first person to
think of
this no that's what John told me and
people do it all the time but like this
guy pumpkin head is a big beer that
comes out this guy had so much Sur plus
he know what to do with it then he made
ice Pig vodka boom yeah so so that's
what you're going to do going down that
path as well yeah but here's the beauty
right like I'm not I'm an equal owner
right but I know my value is is in the
these pearly whites I smile I shake some
hands I put some money in right so out
of the the owners of the brewery we have
one guy that his son's a brew master and
he's um gonna like help out and work
there we have the other guy he's put
money in he's a builder he's going to
build it all the other guy is um me and
I'm just going to like shake hands make
deals and hey drink my beer cuz I have
arms and legs people just feel bad for
me I spoke to like the national whole
billers association or something out in
Vegas and like they love me and they'll
bring me back and I'll be like hey guys
I need all you guys to buy my beer and
sell it and all of a sudden Dogfish had
Brewing is not the only one that sold
for $18 million what what but then I
visualiz what do you know the name of
your Brewing be they're going to call it
Castle Island Brewery Castle Island no
that's a lie that's a lie that's a
different that's a different road that I
drive on it's going to be called Island
Park Brewing I got to get that out of my
Head Island Park Brewing Island Park cuz
right across from where my restaurant is
there's a bridge make sure you get the
URL for that like immediately yeah cuz
otherwise someone's going to buy it as
soon as they hear this and they're going
to sell it back to you for
$100,000 all right cuz I want I want to
be call humble beginnings anyway I want
humble beginnings Brewery but okay well
so I might buy that too we'll see buy
that both yeah
no I mean I don't know I just my wife
wants me to slow down but this is all
stuff that I have business partners in
that we all know our role kind of like
I'm not going to go there and lug kegs
you know I would I'm just handicapp but
but I definitely will promote it and try
to get more people to drink it but you
won't lug kegs I mean I might kick one
over and kind of you know push it m
that's my
ability awesome man well does that get
us up to speed are we there we up to I
mean I just hope everybody wants to come
hang out with with me in in Maine cuz it
gets lonely up there Winters are long
best time to visit not in February if
you guys go there in February I won't be
there but you're more than welcome where
do you go do you go somewhere else for
Real uh for like uh yeah Arizona or
something no Florida Florida uhhuh yeah
just just like for a week yeah like the
kids get a school week off we go when I
say a week I mean my wife pushes it to
like 10 days which really turns into
like two weeks good but I like it we
have a a rent property outside of Disney
so
sweet hey where can people find you so
you got Travis ms.org that's you that's
me you got Travis Mills foundation.org Y
and then you got Lakeside lodging.com
you got the white Duck Pub or Pub and
Brewery something.com we're really not
sure 100% I think I think all yeah yeah
just traps.org the website has all the
little tiles I believe there I don't
know then you got you're on Twitter
you're on Facebook you're on Instagram I
tell you what Instagram been growing
I've been doing some fun videos yeah
taking a page out book I was like hey
Ian da actually set me up with with Evan
Ian's like look this guy's he's talented
you're going to love him he's my
roommate now and he's going to come do
videos for you and I said look all I
want is reels I want shorts and reels
and he's been doing pretty well yeah I
know he's he's cutting some good stuff
man uh but that's SSG SSG Travis Mills
and then you're on Facebook you're on
Twitter and you're apparently you're in
love with yourself on the gram is what I
just heard I'm not in love I want a
bunch of reals of myself yeah yeah yeah
nothing wrong with
that I mean do you know how much let me
tell you something before I see any of
my videos on on Facebook and Instagram I
see you sitting talking to a mic giving
motivation like every day oh you don't
want that okay I see the difference yeah
I'm like hey I want that in my life and
you're like I don't want it just kind of
happens kind of happens here ech I don't
know what echo's doing over there he's
got a camera looks like maybe maybe he's
going to do something with it it's not
all I'm just I'm just here to say what
I'm going to say in the microphone it
dude yeah I don't know I don't know
what's going to happen I do my part you
know I'm not you're not lugging kegs I'm
not turning on the camera I'm just here
doing what I'm supposed to do yeah
exactly exactly check uh Echo Charles
yes any questions I don't oh how do you
power your arm you like USB something
like that see the little the little gold
things in there so that's it's a
magnetic charger the special one yeah it
lights up it lights up green and when it
when the little light on is green it
means it's charger when it shuts off
it's done is that carbon fiber it is
yeah bro I love carbon fiber go ahead
you can touch it it's not work for me if
you notice the mango Mayhem can carbon
fiber the old one the old one yeah yeah
yeah not the not the new one not the new
one you got denied the carbon fiber hey
it is what it is good to see you always
oh good to see you too and I'm not sure
um we supposed to talk about the any of
the beef stuff or no is that
yeah Ste I was just so fortunate that
you were like hey yo I'm going to start
this Beef Company you can be a part of
it if you want and I'm like I'm all
about it I'm all about about it yeah
yeah well I didn't start it but luckily
uh actually Brian kind of spearheaded
that thing and he made connections with
Jeff and they put together so Colorado
craft beef that's right Colorado craft
beef I have that going on too yeah I'm
saying that because I the last
investment I did where I told my wife to
believe in me you know I'm saying Rebel
for good.com um no we try you're trying
to recover from that yeah man it's
awesome uh great people great company
great steaks the steaks are freaking
delicious so did they do ji- Jitsu
before or they just tried it that time
when they came to the camp uh no I think
he's kind of like into training now yeah
yeah you know so I hope everybody out
there like listening those when they
come to when they come to the camp the
Jiu-Jitsu Camp over there in Camp Laurel
in Maine I'm only 20 minutes down the
road so I will I come out in a Heckle
you know we should do something like
where people can swing by you know we go
by the factory we should do something
like just like come by or something come
by the facility every like every Friday
cuz I'm not sure what days you guys are
doing now but every Friday like the
families always leave so like it's just
open getting clean but it's open check
it to it that'd be cool for people to be
come and check it out maybe like get to
meet you and stuff like that that'd be
pretty cool I mean you come down to Camp
so people can meet you there but well I
felt bad I didn't even go to the purple
and the blue belt you know you straight
to Black yeah that's how you roll that's
people were like took me 20 years to get
over here I'm like took me day two yeah
you know so craft beef look you're going
to you need steak get yourself some
steak people there it is uh Travis any
closing thoughts bro you know um look
everybody's biggest problems their
biggest problem my problems don't out
away anybody else's uh whatever Joo Ekko
go through um don't out away anybody
else's and we're on this together so uh
I hope that this podcast has been fun as
well as you know maybe opened your eyes
to uh new ways to think about your
situations that you go through your
loved ones go through and if you uh want
to get the book bounce back by all means
go ahead but if this is enough
information take it take it and run with
it cuz you got legs to do
that I got running legs too it takes me
a while to put them
on well I can tell you that if you got
something out of this podcast you should
definitely get the book because the book
has infinitely more information
infinitely more stories details that are
really going to help everyone out so uh
yeah man get the book and Travis man
thank you once again it's always an
honor to be able to talk to you be able
to have you um thanks for joining us
thanks for writing these books both
these books are awesome and um you know
thanks for your service thanks for your
sacrifice thanks for the service and
sacrifice of your family and most of all
bro thanks for being un inspiration to
everybody I appreciate you you guys are
so awesome you say nice things I'm
telling you what he's got the secret
sauce all Big Mac over there but uh on
top of that on top of that I will say I
appreciate the fact that you have the
book and it's all like went through and
highlighted because I talked with Jenna
I said hey so yeah she's like you going
to come promote your book and come down
I like yeah absolutely how would you
think about it she goes I only got it on
PDF I'm like I I gave Leif like the like
the third or second edition ever handed
out he goes yeah it's buried on my desk
she had no idea he even had it since
Camp oh just saying when are you going
down there well I'm going to try to line
a few things up so she she'll have time
to read it yeah oh yeah no she's already
read that on I think PDF I sent her like
the manuscript but the point was I'm
glad that you actually care about it and
Pete was like talking about how he cares
about it but then I talked to Le and
he's like yeah it's it's on my desk I'm
sorry I didn't tell you dude I was my
dad was at my house this was like a few
years ago when I only had one book the
book extreme ownership and like my dad
was over my house and I don't know what
he said or whatever and he's like yeah
need to take extreme ownership he said
to me and I was like have you even read
the book and he was like I could see
immediately he had and read I was like
bro I was like Hey Dad
you might want to check it out before
you start trying to talk smack to me
that's like my uh my wife someone say
like oh my gosh your husband when he
said this in his presentation and she
just goes like yeah she's never seen me
speak ever oh really yeah she don't care
yeah she doesn't care she's heard
nothing she's out by the pool hanging
out waiting for me to go on another work
trip you know oh man awesome uh yeah man
like I said thanks for coming appreciate
it appreciate everything you do man and
you're my hero quit it stop me blush
you're my hero you guys both are so
awesome thank you guys thanks
bro and with that Travis Mills has left
the building yes and left
us with some
lessons and some leadership and some
inspiration yep
literally nothing to complain about on
Earth yeah you know which one stuck with
me which that like in dayto day that dog
don't hunt BR sometimes bro you got to
just got to let it go and you know you
get and I get it and I said that thing
earlier for a reason where it's like it
trickles down to your everyday life
because that's what most of us are
dealing with most of the time and I
tried to make that point at the end like
just because you might feel like you're
not going through any major problems
right now it's still there's you are
going through things and these things
will help you with everything that
you're dealing with and one of those
things for sure is that dog don't hunt
even the small problems even and even
Travis he does such a good job in saying
hey I realize my situation is very
extreme compared to other people's bad
situations and really he's all even go
one further and be like hey these
principles apply to things that you
wouldn't even look at and be like oh
that's a bad situation just like you
it's a it's a way to choose to look at
certain situations if they don't go the
way that you wanted them to go in that
moment super small situations if you're
just the idea if you just take that one
where that dog don't hunt bro the idea
of just just let it go bro Just Let It
Go instead of looking you know how they
say Don't Look Behind look forward you
know move forward BR that's a big deal
when you can remember it it helps you a
lot for sure for sure and when you when
you can do it with something as severe
as what Travis has been been through it
means that the rest of us can do it over
some much much smaller things and medium
things and big things and that's the the
point that he made was like oh your
biggest problem is like your biggest
problems I I remember that what the
lesson I learned from that or the time I
learned that was with my kids yeah and
like I was in the teams we had war going
on and people were getting killed and
like my daughter you know whatever one
of my daughters was like like a a c on a
test in school or whatever in third
grade yeah that's real and I'm and my my
attitude like for a split second like
you this doesn't matter and then I
realized oh this is the biggest problem
that she has in the world and this is
her world that's another thing I always
trying to remember P we look essentially
are we all in the same world yes we are
sure but everyone's in their own world
yep and whatever's going on in your
world is what's going on in your world
well the rest of the world doesn't even
matter compared to what's going on in
your world so especially you get those
teenage years like you're 16 years old
and you get dumped by your girlfriend
those dudes get broke up bro yeah
mentally so for those dudes and females
too girls happens to them too so tons of
lessons you know we forgot to mention
that also you know uh Travis Mills was
talking about all the different things
that he's involved he's also in Joo fuel
by the way yep you know so he's one of
the one of the shareholders over at jao
fuel so if you want to support Joo fuel
it's going to help out across the board
all aspects hydrate uh greens you the
greens man underrated maybe they're not
even underrated just maybe I need to do
a better job of telling people about the
greens the greens are the best yeah uh
hands down we got go RTD we already
talked about that um MK can't drink too
many Eko just pointed out I think you
got to really try cuz I think I think if
you are drinking for a day you're good
yeah well yeah so and what I really
meant cuz only because cuz I reth
thought about it the whole thing when I
said it too I was like wait that that I
don't even know if me saying it the way
I did is as accurate as the message I
was trying to say given what Travis said
cuz he was talking about like oh I want
to stay slim and you know when you're
when you're running a calorie deficit
right you ever heard of that yeah run a
calorie deficit cuz you want to lose
weight right the right the correct way
and all this stuff what I'm saying is if
you're not necessarily quote unquote
focusing on a calorie deficit or if you
are focusing on a calorie deficit but
you're like I'll just drink these Ms cuz
they're you know it's better than eating
like a whole freaking uh double burger
with cheese and bacon or something like
this from the white duck in or where
yeah or what have you um you just got to
be careful with that cuz if you're
pounding yeah four or five MKS a day
because they're good and you're like oh
yeah freaking I'm cleared hot yeah I got
the green light as you guys say the cool
thing about a MK though and I I
experienced this today no I experienced
it last night I got home like kind of
late from Jiu-Jitsu from training H and
so I had a lunch late lunch at like 2:30
and my late lunch was just like I was
like oh I'm just going to have something
light cuz we're going to have dinner in
a little while and we're going to have
steaks so I was fired up so I was I'll
just have a MK so I had a RTD MK and and
and honestly I had a protein cookie I
had a MK cookie but then I then 3 hours
go by and it's time for a ribeye steak
Yeah by the way mhm so I'm fired up you
know
and I didn't eat the whole thing I ate
like half of it you know got that Primal
beef I was all fired up yeah Primal
beef.com got myself a ribeye you know
what I mean so I'm all fired up and it's
delicious but I was full yeah already
full so anyways uh joof fuel.com go
there get your stuff get what you need
get it's cold season coming get your
immunity gigs back up get your cold war
on get your vitamin D make sure you're
taking that you can get this stuff at
Wawa you can get vitamin shop GNC
military commissaries AES Haner Dash
stores wake Fern shop right HB down in
TAS been doing us right same with Meer
up in the Midwest Harris Teeter Lifetime
Fitness Shields small gyms all over the
place Jiu-Jitsu gyms if you want to sell
joof fuel CrossFit Gyms you want to sell
joof fuel JF sales joof fuel.com give
your clients what they need to get
better so we got that going for us also
you just talking about origin USA
tonight talking about origin USA making
stuff in America we got factories in
America that's what we got we don't have
slave labor overseas in dangerous
factory settings breathing chemicals
dumping chemicals into the atmosphere
and into the water which is what they're
doing in the clothes that you're buying
if you're not buying from origin USA so
go to origin usa.com help the National
Security of this country by bringing
back manufacturing what else you need to
know oh you want to know what we have we
have workout gear we have Jiu-Jitsu gear
we have rashguards GES we have T-shirts
hoodies heavy hoodies light hoodies
medium hoodies kilo
hoodies jeans heavy jeans Factory light
jeans
Delta boots hats you just go there go
there and get some americanmade stuff
yeah it's true help across the board we
also have uh another store that's been
very creatively named Joo store oh yeah
chos store.com that's the discipline
equals Freedom branch of this whole
representation thing thing that we're
doing on the path so yeah disal Freedom
good you know all that all that uh type
of stuff so Jo
store.com is where you get it also
there's a subscription scenario don't
want to forget about that you want a new
shirt every month new design a little
bit more you know interesting type
designs little layers in there um that's
where you can get it can you get the old
shirts you can get the past shirts yes
if you subscribe like if you sub shirt
Locker you subscribe right now but you
want the you also want the shirt from
last year I don't know October whatever
last year yes you can get it the reason
I asked that is because I believe there
were some backdoor channels utilized by
my children MH to get past shirts M and
I thought they pulled some strings yeah
which they did apparently yes they did
uh so the my point in saying that though
is the designs are at a level of
coolness that even my own children yep
were like yo got to represent that one
represent oh yeah yeah there's a few one
hey there's a few of them and it's
interesting cuz it's been going on for
what I don't know a while more than a
year so there's like a backlog of
designs that people just kind of are not
familiar with so they'll see like me or
someone you know someone from the
beginning days or whatever wearing would
be like hey where did that shirt come
from like oh what did you know where did
I get that shirt where do I get that
shirt that's where you get it that's
going be the answer first world problems
good shirt yeah the toxic productivity
shirt oh yeah so there you go some good
shirts uh subscription shirt Locker
store.com Primal beef.com get that get
that beef from the shann andoa valley oh
yeah or Colorado craft beef.com get that
beef from the Colorado
goodness we also have a underground
podcast Jo underground.com we answer
your questions it cost $818 a month
that's how we can own it it's a plat
form that we own if you can't afford it
we still want you there assistance atj
underground.com check it out YouTube
subscribe psychological warfare get it
Flipside canvas Dakota Meer making cool
stuff to hang on your wall bunch of
books obviously the books for today
bounce
back 12 Warrior principles to reclaim
and recalibrate your life so get this
book going to help you with everything
that you're doing also the last book
that he wrote which is phenomenal tough
as they come man just check out podcast
90 but get that book as well and then
obviously I've written a bunch of books
you might want to check those out as
well especially those kids books come
on get look you want to stay on the
crappy path and not get books for
yourself don't want to get discipline
freedom field manual you don't want to
get leadership strategy and tactics
revised Expanded Edition okay okay
that's fine you don't want to do it you
want to stay on a rut okay but if don't
do that to your kids or the neighbor
kids or your nephew right get him the
warrior kid books get them Mikey and the
dragons that's what we're talking about
about ashon front ashon front.com we
have a leadership consultancy we can
help your business we can help your team
we can help you in life in everything
that you do by teaching you leadership
we can come into your organization go to
Asam front.com to check that out we also
have the extreme ownership Academy
online it's extreme ownership. comom
that's going to help you in life it's
going to help you in business it's going
to help you with your family it's going
to help you interacting with other human
beings it's going to help you lead
yourself to Victory ownership. and if
you want to help service members active
and retired you want to help their
families you want to help gold star
families check out Mark Lee's mom mama
Lee she's got a charity organization if
you want to donate or you want to get
involved go to Americas Mighty
warriors.org she is helping out so many
people with that program also check out
Heroes and horses. org Mike a taking
people into the dang Backwoods of
Montana
where they get lost so they can get
found and Jimmy May has got his
organization beyondthe
brotherhood. org and
obviously obviously Travis Mills
foundation.org you heard what he's
doing and if you want to connect with us
Travis is on Instagram apparently making
his shorts
reals hell yeah and he's on
Twitter SSG Travis Mills that stands for
staff sergeant and echo's there as well
as am I echo's at Echo Charles I'm at Jo
just be careful cuz there's an algorithm
that's trying to grab you by the back of
the neck and kill you that's what's
going on so don't let it
happen thanks once again to Travis for
joining us the ultimate human
being honored to talk to you and have
you as a friend thank you for being who
you are and thanks to all the men and
women in the milit milary thank you for
your service especially grateful for all
of the re-calibrated
Warriors who have served and sacrificed
so much thank you all for our freedom
and also thanks to our police and law
enforcement firefighters paramedics EMTs
dispatchers correctional officers border
patrol Secret Service and all First
Responders thank you for your service
here on the home front to keep us safe
every day and to everyone else out
there
I know life is a struggle struggle
you're going to face struggle and it can
be rough it can be really rough but
don't forget that while you can't choose
the trauma that you are
dealt you can choose how you respond to
it and if Travis Mills can carry on like
Travis Mills carries
on then I think we can all step up every
day and get after it
and until next time this is EO and Joo
out